Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just checking in on you.
Um,
we're recording this thing.
I don't know where am I going to put this on?
I might just do a special episode because I'm now I'm already thinking that
people are going to be like,
well,
how come you didn't talk any Stanley Cup final fuck it.
Action here.
I have with me one of my,
uh,
one of my favorite people.
What am I a great friends in this business since the late fucking nineties.
He has a new documentary coming out on the all things comedy network about the
amazing Jonathan called always amazing,
the wonderful,
talented Mr Steve Byrne.
Thank you.
Thank you William.
He liked that.
Can you follow that intro?
Did I go too big?
I think you,
you hit the sweet spot and I got to tell you I was sick about this all the way
over.
You are part of the two greatest,
um,
events I ever had cause I grew up playing hockey and all right.
You and I played.
You can actually play.
I'm fun to skate around.
I make you look good out.
This play we played at the United Center together in Chicago.
Yeah.
Uh,
and we had the whole rink to ourselves.
And then you and I got to play in the Mario Lemieux fantasy camp.
Well,
back up Vince Vaughn set that up.
The Big Chicago guy.
Yeah.
And I'm in business with Vince doing F is for family short because of you
because you introduced me to Vince while I remember.
He um,
oh God.
I remember one.
I was just like,
when I,
I kind of moved,
I think you had just moved her something.
Yeah.
And it was down the Improv and he had come out to see your set and you actually,
most la people would try to hoard that connection.
Be like this,
this a list.
Movie Star is mine.
Right.
And you were like,
hey man,
I'm doing a spot tonight if you want to come down on the show.
You asked,
because I wasn't even on that show.
You said,
I'm bringing Vince down.
You should meet him and say hello.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
through that I took a meeting with them and that's when I was totally
disgruntled is weird.
I had moved to La and I was completely over Hollywood because I can never get
anything.
And you had just moved here?
Yes.
Yeah,
it did that,
that,
that didn't take too long.
That's me.
No,
no,
no.
I was already over it.
I was just like,
I'm coming out here and I'm just going to do parts on other people's things
because my things do not get picked up.
And then you get into a deal and then they just take you,
they tee it,
takes you out of play.
Oh,
he's in a deal.
We can't,
he,
you know,
we would be second position to his project and no one wants to be that.
So then your pilot wouldn't get picked up.
You weren't in anything and you just,
you were another year older.
So I was just like,
fuck this.
Yeah.
So that's when I took the meeting with Vince's company with Peter Billingsley
and he goes,
what do you got?
And I go,
nothing.
What do you got?
And he was like,
all right.
I go,
dude,
none of my shit gets picked up.
Everything's considered misogynistic,
homophobic,
fucking else phobic or saying it.
They're probably going Ding,
Ding,
Ding.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't,
don't owe them.
You're in the club.
Yeah.
And it's just like every fucking thing that I do is like was labeled.
So unless I had a,
it's gotten to the point,
this is pre me too.
Sure.
Yeah.
It was like,
well what if I had a guy come out with his junk tucked between his thighs?
Okay.
We like that it was so fucking ready.
And this whole fucking thing that they say women don't have power in Hollywood.
I've,
I,
I never met him.
I met one or two male casting directors.
I never got to that level of,
you know,
the Harvey Weinstein Guy Wanting to watch you take a shower,
whatever fucking level that is.
I know what you watch him take a shower.
I never got to that level.
I never did,
did cast him directly.
I'll tell you this,
this,
when I first moved here,
I never forgot this cause I think you and I somewhat have a,
an Irish temper,
but I got,
Oh yeah dude,
I'm going to therapy for my temper right after this.
I got a Korean and Irish too.
So the,
you know,
the Koreans are the Irish of Asia.
I don't know if you've used that rail.
Yeah,
cause you know it's like it's,
we love Whiskey,
we love fighting,
we love,
we love booze and we love storytelling.
Where the funnest ones to hang out with in Asia,
we love potatoes and cabbage.
We hate the sun.
It's like,
yeah,
all the other Chinese and Japanese people agree with this.
Do they have to give it up to the Koreans?
Yeah,
yeah.
K Pop.
Yeah.
Tanners are always the big ones there.
You know,
it's all the Asian stars.
Or would you say you have the most flavor as the young kid saying,
I can't even say that you Q can never like even like Timberland,
I cringe when I have to say that.
It's like,
can I just say Timberland?
But anyways,
when I first moved here,
I was driving to this audition and this,
this fucking bitch in this Mercedes would not like,
like let me through whatever.
And uh,
finally we get to this light and she's jockeying for position.
I'm jocking for position where get off the four or five.
We'd go to this light and I just wrote mine.
I went on,
I'm like,
fuck you,
you fucking page.
And she goes,
fuck you,
you music shit.
So we're 10 minutes later,
I,
I sign in the audition I signed and everything.
I opened up the door,
she's the cast and director.
Oh No,
you'll put up the door.
I just go have a good day.
And I just shut the door,
got my car.
And I was like,
did she recognize you?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
She knew.
And I knew as soon as I open it,
I just like,
I just looked at it,
I was like,
fuck it.
Yeah.
But she knows something.
I love that you owned it and didn't fucking do the audition.
Cause my dumb ass would've done,
it will be like,
hi.
Then I would've,
I would've gone through with the wacky next door neighbor,
hey dude,
talk more about,
uh,
some of the like Asia stuff because it's never covered over here.
And I did some gigs over there and was like fascinated where I literally felt I
went to an alternate universe where you go over there,
there's first of all,
there's way more people.
It's just entirely different part of the world that is doing just fine without
fucking western culture or any of that.
And when we never talked,
I go over their own airlines on doctors,
the whole fucking thing.
Like you,
you grow up like reading our history and you feel like in than less,
you know,
Europeans or yeah.
Or are white Americans or has somehow have their hand on it.
It either doesn't count or it won't work or whatever.
And I went over there and I fucking loved it.
I felt like I went to another planet.
Yeah.
It just,
the cars are a little smaller and the vending machines are a little shorter,
but they get,
but you go over there,
you know what,
this is like the perfect example,
right.
So Hollywood's been around forever and then they have crazy rich Asians.
Right.
And it's celebrated like it's a good movie.
Right,
right.
I don't think it's great.
Like the same way I think black panthers.
It's a good movie.
I don't think it's amazing.
It's not right.
That was doing a bit on that.
How it scared White Hollywood was that they nominated for best picture.
It's like all right,
it was good.
He Goes,
God,
I don't think that's up there with the godfather and raging bull.
It's no,
no.
So this,
this thing comes out and everyone was like,
oh my God,
isn't this great?
Didn't we do a good job?
And then you know where that movie bombed fucking China cause they're like,
yeah guys,
we do this shit all the time and have incredible movies over there.
Yeah.
Cause Bobby Lee,
Bobby Lee told me like I had to stop asking Bobby because Bobby League,
just watch his car.
He's the one that told me about old boy.
Old Boy.
Yeah.
And then the audition audition's Cree.
It's,
it's disgusting.
Itchy,
the killer and all that stuff.
It's almost not scary as much as it's just disturbing and yeah,
like you can't kind of shake it,
so don't,
if you're already fucked up,
they're there.
They're going to,
people listening are going to watch him play.
Um,
but this is how my little understand agent,
it seems like Japan is the white people of Asia where they feel like they are at
the top of the food chain and they are,
the,
everything that they do is the greatest.
And they tried to take everybody over but,
and that also seems because of them geographically,
they're on an island and they're kind of like,
they've kind of like they can't grow out anymore.
Yeah.
What's fucked up about them as do you know they had a war with Russia last
century in one and when they claim their land,
all the white countries like Nah,
Nah,
give it back.
That's sort of the prequel to them.
Pearl Harbor on all of that.
Like,
cause anytime a white country would do that to another white country,
another way country,
you've got the spoils of victory and they won.
Yeah.
It was like they played for fucking USC with Pete Carroll and like,
Nah.
Gimme gimme gimme that Heisman trophy back.
Give me,
what are you talking about dude?
I fucking,
I ran photos.
Yards.
Nah,
no,
no.
Well I think like Koreans are,
cause I,
you know China like,
like we,
we think like,
you know,
we spent time in New York City obviously and you think Manhattan,
New York City,
you know,
if you can make it there,
you can make it,
you go to any of these cities,
like you go to Beijing,
you go to,
you know anything and it's like,
it absolutely dwarfs Manhattan.
Manhattan is absolutely,
it's almost like Manhattan becomes like a block comparatively to these other
cities.
So Hong Kong was like that.
You always driving to the airport and I was seeing clusters of Manhattan.
It seemed like that were apartment complexes.
Not Dude,
let's,
let's be honest here.
It's an environmental disaster over there as far as how many fucking people
there are.
Of course.
Yeah.
Great people.
Not saying anything bad about him,
but that you need to get rid of.
Like,
I don't know how many it's got.
The numbers got to come way the fuck down.
This is like when they had the Olympics over there and like China,
like nobody could move for three days.
So all the dust would settle me down and then they shut.
If they sent out those rockets to,
to like disperse the clouds so that you can have sun to,
to get rid of all the smog.
I was over there.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
And this is,
that's what,
well that's what the fuck.
But he hadn't spoken and leaving the car running and just like that Papa,
Papa,
Papa 70th truck,
you know the guy's smoking and stuff.
That's what it's gotta be a better way I think.
Eventually I think they're up against it and they're gonna figure it out.
That's what I'm hoping they're going to be forced to at some point.
Yeah.
I think at that point where if nobody couldn't lift,
you have to shut down a host city just to get a clear day.
You would think.
Now,
this is the thing that I heard about.
The reason I'll China's population got the way it was was because Chapin kept
attacking them and then whoever their leader was,
his whole thing is we're going to have so many people that no matter how many
you attack,
there's always going to be another 100,000 coming over the hill like this.
Never ending Braveheart.
And I was there just like fucking,
they're way too supremacy.
Like you can't fuck with us.
Now let me,
is there any truth to that?
And this is so ridiculous that you're American,
but because you have your half Asian,
but I feel like,
you know,
all of this stuff didn't go to Kent State University,
his escort in Ohio and studied like the history of Asia.
I,
I barely know what I know about my folks.
You know you went to school?
I went to Kent State.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Do they have like a little memorial shrine?
That's why those kids got a get shot,
right?
Yeah.
I was there for,
I forget,
I think it was like the 25th anniversary.
I don't know.
What did you ever have the balls to protest anything on that campus?
Did you just think,
oh no,
but did you feel like it's more like if you fly in this same airline that had a
plane crash the day before he like what are the odds?
Like what are the odds the national guard is going to come in and blow away some
more students here.
But I got bad luck.
It would be like the odds are astoundingly incredibly against me.
Why is that?
I think it's,
I remember when you these law,
no,
but you will one of those fucking guys,
you do a late night set at the comic strip and everyone would have a tough time.
Yup.
But you somehow would have the crowd with a guy picks up the chair.
I remember he threw it and hit you in the head.
You got cut.
Cause I remember they put staples in your head,
shot at the comic strip.
Make,
make it seem like you had stitches.
Yeah.
Then then,
uh,
somebody wrote underneath my head shot had said the chairman,
the chairman,
Steve Byrne.
Uh,
I don't know.
I remember that night I was at the,
uh,
I was at the comic strip and this is like another thing I do that's probably
stupid,
but I take the onus always on myself,
right.
And I always say,
what could I have done better that situation.
And what happened was I was my birthday dude,
it was my birthday and I'd worked on this spin.
I was so excited to,
you know,
it was like that at that time of your life where you just like,
I just got to try this bit out.
Right.
And what did the comic Strip,
11 o'clock,
late night.
And there's all these like Jersey moocs and they stand up and they were,
they're debating,
they're check while I'm doing my set in front of 10 people.
Yeah.
And uh,
I go,
guys,
come on.
Can we just keep it down?
I just want to go through this.
And the guy goes,
what are you going to do some Kung Fu?
Me,
I,
okay,
okay.
Here.
Oh,
we went,
ratio,
you went racial.
And then early I was like,
Yup.
At earlier,
it's always racial.
And,
and then I go,
well,
thank God the,
uh,
the Lincoln tunnel is open 24 hours and then his girlfriend starts piping in and
they're young by the lucky chance shit at me.
And Jackie Chan there,
call me Jackie Chan.
This is when I had my lego head hair when it was just grown out.
And you guys were shitting on me at the cellar for this bouffant of like Asian
hair.
You were kind of asking for it.
I was asking for.
It was like,
yeah,
might as well go on stage.
Dressed like a leprechaun.
I mean,
so this girl starts piping up and she goes,
she said something about me being a I g I just go,
well,
somebody did somebody tell that cut to shut up.
I knew this.
And then this,
this barstool gets chucked,
Whiz Bang,
hit the back of my head.
Just felt like hot tea running down my neck and eight staples in the back of my
head later.
And the cops came to visit me at the Ho at the hospital.
They're like,
you should press charges.
And I was like,
I did it.
I should've,
I should've handled it better.
It's my own amazing though.
Like how different that time,
what year was that?
That was probably 99 2000 how different the world is now where they would be all
of this video.
Oh yeah.
You would be considered this victim of racial hate.
I hate crime.
Yeah,
you,
your Twitter followers would have gone up by half a million.
You would be like,
you'd be an arena act.
But now I'm an outcast.
I get then back then,
back then it was just like if you were Asian,
you had to take the fact that,
Hey Jackie Chair,
why don't you go fucking go run with the Rick Shaw?
You had to deal with all that and then,
and then,
and they throw a stool at you.
What you want to know this,
this happened at the comedy store.
It's always racial with the common story.
Remember the dark days at the store and nobody was going,
I don't know if you had been,
oh yeah,
no and,
and I gotta tell you something.
I'm all like,
cause everybody says New York.
If I can make it there,
it can make it anywhere.
Yeah.
La is infinitely harder.
Cause you know,
the thing about New York was I felt I could escape the business where it was
just like my neighbor was,
you know,
uh,
whatever was his financial bullshit or,
or worked at a gym or like my roommate,
like he,
he was into hockey and fucking worked at the rinks in,
in central park.
He was in a completely different fucking world is an Irish immigrant and he's
fucking doing construction over here.
It's just everybody is this fucking thing in this thing.
And then there was also like the hierarchy where it was like,
as bad as New York was,
I wasn't competing with television and movie stars who were popping in and every
night and they would go in and have nothing to say and burned the light for 90
fucking minutes as you sat bombing
because,
because they had the TV credit,
I W I was at the store and again it was maybe 10 people there and this group of
Asian kids gets up and walks out.
As I'm walking onto the stage of being introduced,
and there's this dude in the back with four of his buddies is eating chicken
wings.
He brought his own wings in,
right?
[inaudible] he's,
and before I even hit the mic,
he goes,
hey,
your friends left funny.
He goes,
your friends left.
And as he says it,
he's eating chicken wings.
He doing that with a fingers,
look in a sauce off and fucking infuriated me.
I go,
you see,
you're saying my friends left because I'm Asian and they're Asian.
He goes,
yeah,
that's what I said.
I go,
well,
maybe I should go outside and catch up with them.
Maybe you should meet me.
He goes,
maybe I will.
So he gets up and I get up and I,
you know that,
you know,
the finishes said I didn't even start it item and tell one joke.
I get to the corner,
this is when I was,
I was,
I would get hopped up zero to 60 and I just fucking like drill this guy in the
face dropping to the ground and I just started fucking whale on.
Unlike Ralphie and a Christmas story,
I'm fucking beaten the shit out of us.
And this guy,
I didn't know this,
this guy picks up one of those tables in the back,
you know,
I heavy those things are,
he goes to like swing and hit me with this table.
Thank God Bret Ernst saved my life.
I'd probably be eating out of a straw in a fucking wheelchair right now.
But he t he tackled the guy and took that guy out and then I think one or two
other comics came in and subdued their other friends.
And then they pulled me off the guy and the guy called the cops the next day and
was threatening to sue and everything for what exactly is in a fight.
And then Tommy said,
didn't you make fun of him for being Asian?
He's like,
yeah.
And then he backed down so that,
that kind of happened too.
So that's always like weird ones.
Jesus man.
Yeah.
Well let's talk about your movie,
Steve.
Now I see why you went behind the camera here on this one.
Give yourself a break from these,
uh,
MMA matches.
You had that blip.
I bet on the other end of things too,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Well I remember,
yeah,
you will.
You would having a cab drive,
you will get in a steak and cheese and next thing you know you had a broken jaw
at a broken jaw.
Yeah.
And then they had to shut down Sullivan and son for like six months,
weeks,
six weeks.
Anybody breaks their jaw.
I go six weeks and athletes,
Sidney Crosby broke his jaw.
Actually Sidney Crosby broke his jaw the day I broke my jaw.
And that's how big a penguins fan you are.
That kind of synchronicity.
It's like when women's periods lineup,
it's the same thing.
You and Sidney Crosby,
Bluetooth,
we're sinking up.
Yeah,
no,
the film is always amazing.
It's his documentary I did about the amazing Jonathan,
great comic magician.
That was one of the first comics to pop off at comedy central when they did
those half hours and they were starting to really get some notoriety.
And Joel,
I saw that guy from way,
way back in the day.
Like he like I the,
I'm such a huge fan of that guy.
And,
uh,
if you never saw the amazing Jonathan,
he,
I felt like he was the first guy who really,
uh,
did that whole thing where he just kind of see the tree.
It wasn't about the trick necessarily was about the trick going bad and,
but he added a whole new like sort of spin to that where he had like the whole
rock and roll look and a Freddy Krueger comedy and he looks really like,
he did look like you didn't know what the fuck was going to happen.
I loved him.
Yeah.
He's definitely like more of a rock star but definitely more of a comedian than
a magician.
And you're right.
Like everything he did you could almost kind of see it and then sometimes the
trucks would go bad,
but he just didn't give it like,
yeah,
he was just kind of like this makeshift kind of comic on the fly involved in
magic.
And I,
he was one of the,
when I,
when I first went on the road,
I did back to back weekends at Charlie Goodnight's back in the day.
And my first week was Brian Regan and the second weekend was he amazing.
Jonathan and I struck up a friendship with him and his road manager,
Joel Osborne,
who's a huge oasis fan and we just bonded over that.
So every time I came out here,
my first TV quarter was Beatty's comic view and I crashed at Jonathan's house.
Few of those I did I think two or three.
But so when I think of my first TV set,
I think a common view and then celebrating with those guys.
And uh,
you know,
Jonathan went on Vegas headliner and he was given a terminal diagnosis due to
cardiomyopathy where it's a degradation of your heart breaking down in his
heart's operating I think at like 60 to 50% capacity right now.
So wow.
That combined with a lifelong drug addiction and the fact that he's still a drug
addict and diabetes compounded upon that,
Jesus was told,
you got,
you got to get your affairs in order.
That's enough to kill Jim Morrison a couple of times.
That's amazing.
He's still going.
Yeah.
So he basically retired from comedy and performing and hung it all up and
outlived expectations.
I think due to the fact that he's buying stem cells off the black market in
Mexico.
And he basically said F,
you know,
like a year ago,
two years ago that he wanted to see if he still had it.
He was getting tired of waiting around to die.
Can I still,
can I still perform?
Do I still have this?
And he made a return to stage and did three shows and I thought that's such a
great impetus to,
to,
to follow and what a great trajectory cause you get to tell the story of his,
of his,
um,
of his career.
But the heart can't wait to fucking see this thing.
Well the heart and soul of it really is about Joel Osborne.
See when
Jonathan Jonathan's the face of the dock,
the heart of the documentary is when he was touring worldwide.
He was like Kinda like a Russell Peters back in the day.
He was going everywhere and he met this,
this kid,
he's 12 years old.
He'd always be backstage and asking for autographs and sneaking in the shows and
you just saw this like desire or you know,
fascination with magic and comedy in this kid,
Joel Osborne.
And so he,
he basically took him under his wing and every year he came back to Australia,
Joe would get a little older and he'd give them a little more responsibility and
eventually he was,
he was like,
uh,
like his road manager in Australian and publicizing all the events and putting
posters up everywhere,
Ma and getting a cut of this and selling the magic kit in Australia.
And eventually when Joel turned 18,
he said,
you want to be my road manager in the states?
And Joel said,
yeah.
And eventually Joel,
Joel is a guy that's doing meditation.
He doesn't drink,
he doesn't do drugs in this kid.
It comes out to Vegas and his negotiating million dollar deals with these
casinos and Jonathan's as drug attic and throwing this 18 year old kid in the
middle of this crazy fucking scenarios and just trolls.
Like,
you know,
he tells me this is beyond a dock,
this is a good movie.
He goes,
you go to the golden nugget and you tell those mother fuckers,
Jonathan wants 2.5 you tell me,
shove it up your fucking ass and walk out and slam the door.
And Jill's like,
I guess so.
And so Joel goes in and,
and Joel's very diplomatic and he got everything Jonathan wanted in a very
serene kind of way and so to people on paper should never be in each other's
lives,
developed this great fraternal relationship.
And Joel basically became this like caretakers song through a suicide attempt.
He saw him through drug addiction and he basically got Jonathan in a great place
in his life and eventually said,
okay,
I'm going to go off and become a comedian on my own.
And Joel went to Australia and became a comic and this is about these two
reuniting for one last tour and being on stage together.
And this is on all things comedy.
This sounds like it's going to win an award.
Well,
I,
you know,
we,
we've gone through the gauntlet with this thing and all things comedy and
soapbox had been nothing but kind to us and helps us in terms of two to make a
film like this.
It takes a lot of money.
And I did it all out of my own pocket,
quite a bit.
Money,
quite a lot of money in a hole on this thing.
But Soapbox said,
you know,
I talked to the guys at all,
things calmed me,
they said,
hey,
maybe we can help you get the finishing funds for this and,
and finish the film.
And so they sweeten it for us with color and sound.
Got It together.
And when we were looking for a distribution partner,
we thought let's go to all things comedy and it up perfectly.
So beautiful.
It's just,
I think it's a perfect platform for it given the content.
Nice companies think you're a great guy.
Wife's over there.
She had an idea.
She shooting something right now shooting a pilot.
Yeah,
I went over there.
So it was actually a good,
she was doing that cause we had a little dust up last night as we do.
But you know,
it's funny.
He goes right.
Nah,
she came walking in and she was wearing this purple sweater and she looked
beautiful and I was just saying that that's,
that's how we ended up with her.
I could just never break even in my fantasy of breaking up with her.
I would say when she walked away I would get sad and I would still get a,
I'll get back in here,
come back.
Oh maybe no,
she's,
you know,
whatever.
I was right though last night and I was right.
But you know,
that day,
Monday when
you're right,
dude,
here come the tears.
Did you then,
if it's gone wrong,
yeah,
I'm probably not a good thing to say.
You know,
in those moments like can you get your emotions in check?
You know those,
yeah.
It's probably not good to go fucking bud grant head coach on them at that point.
But I am learning things.
Yeah.
I'm learning things.
Um,
so anyway,
sorry,
we got off track there.
Um,
how long have you been working on thing cause he sings like it takes the thing
take forever.
Well the,
the thing for me is I was doing two at the same time.
I,
I basically did this just to do it just to,
I'd never done a doc.
I love docs,
but I knew enough about story narrative that I was like,
I think I could tell the story and I know these guys so well and I know exactly
the story I want to tell.
So when I did the interview is who was six to eight hours with Jonathan and 68
hours with Joel.
But I knew exactly what to ask them.
You know,
getting the content was different,
getting all the archival footage and converting the archival footage.
That's a whole nother process.
So you was expensive and you were doing this while you were writing that movie?
I did a partner for you last year.
Yes.
And that things coming out like,
dude,
who's working harder than you?
Well,
no wonder I haven't seen you in the clubs and the men even buried in a writer's
room in,
in the editing.
Huh?
Yeah.
I,
I basically wrote the feature on the road while I was kind of,
Eh,
I'd come back Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
edit the documentary,
go on the road Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and write this feature film just to,
as an exercise to see if I could do it and then do shows at night and do shows
at night because I basically thought I had Sullivan and son on the air.
I was the second Asian American ever to have a sitcom and nobody gives a flying
fuck.
What was the first Margaret Margaret show shows and there wasn't another one.
Yeah.
After that,
after that I was a second one,
then came like fresh off.
Then came Dr Ken and fresh off the boat.
I know what that is cause hers didn't work and they were like,
you say yeah to hell with these 10 million billion people.
Exactly.
Oh that is what happened with red heads being leads in movies.
That guy from fucking Nyp de Bleu after one season walked and he did Jayden one
other movie and they didn't do well and they would just like say,
this is why the red head male will never be a lead in a fucking movie.
Ruined everything for you.
He put us on the bench.
Yeah,
he,
he put us,
he put his back into a Richie Cunningham world.
Guy from billions is bringing you back.
Who's that guy?
The dude from billions.
He's red hair.
He's a ginger.
A like a UK actor.
He was in the a band of brothers who's one of the leads and band of brothers.
Hey,
I'm not talking ensemble cast.
I'm saying the fucking film is on your freckled shoulders.
There is a certain,
you know what you know I call,
I call it Hollywood head.
Every once in awhile I'll see that guy has,
he has a Hollywood head,
hits the fucking brown of jet black hair with the cow lick the superman haircuts
.
Look with the square fucking jaw.
If you had blue eyes in that,
that fucking guy is a loser.
I don't care if he can act.
He's a fuck.
He will be.
Listen,
I just want to run my food truck.
I can't tell you dude.
It was so big.
Facial features to those people look weird in real life.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They got giant sucking head.
They look fucking don't they?
They look like they were drawn.
They look good on on screen.
You look good on screen.
Yeah.
I got a big enough head.
I just didn't have the right payment do I can't tell you like back in the day it
was fucking hilarious when I first,
first time I came out here,
this is way back when they had black and white head shots,
which I remember you're one with the staples and it was black and white.
So I don't even act like you're fucking not as you said Billy Bird didn't it?
Uh,
it's I went by William at first.
Yeah.
Then bill,
then Billy,
then back to bill.
I finally just said that like,
cause I was trying to find,
cause everyone was saying like he got a weird last name.
You've got to think I got sucked into that show Biz thing.
And then finally is just like my is bill,
fuck it.
So,
um,
but I don't mind if you call me bill Billy A.
William,
as long as you fucking call me,
I don't give a shit as long as I'm working,
I'm fine.
So,
um,
I ended up like,
I would have like the black,
the black and white headshot.
So with the Moose in the hair in the mid to late nineties,
it looked like I had hair color,
like somewhere between yours and Mirena.
So it looks like brown hair.
So initially on low budget shit,
they,
they would try me out,
they would just look at my credits and not look at my tape or whatever.
And they would,
they would say,
okay,
maybe we'll give this guy shot at the lead and dude,
you know,
prepared three scenes and I would walk in and the second they saw me,
they'd be like,
um,
we're just gonna do the first scene.
And I knew what it was.
It was just like,
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
It says it was this fucking like,
unwritten rule out here.
But I always found it funny because I've always looked at shit like that going
like I know where I'm going.
I I,
this is just,
you know,
like when you back in the day Lucian [inaudible] have enough white guys and then
I was just like,
I know what he's saying.
I would just,
I would just be your first headshot I used to see at stand up.
No work.
You never saw my first test shot.
Not your first official one,
but you were tilted sideways.
You were smiling and you had this great smile on your face.
And I always,
I always thought cause I,
cause I knew you off stage.
I was like,
I bet it pained him to like smile to do that headshot because I can't picture
you like,
cause now your picture see me like that Steven,
now your pictures are like,
they're like you where you're more kind of like well this is what you saw in
that headshot was the smiling me was who I thought I was.
Right.
I didn't realize,
see I have this theory that your twenties is all about.
Like,
I would say this in the podcast that your twenties you just basically taking
your childhood out on people.
Yeah.
If it was a good one or a bad one and you don't even know what you're doing.
Okay.
So if you were raised right,
you're doing something good.
Okay.
But if you're,
you know,
a little off or whatever,
then you're hurting people and somewhere in your thirties you stop blaming
people and you start working on yourself or whatever and then then your 50,
almost 51 you're still in fucking therapy.
So,
um,
what that was was that was prop.
That's who I was.
Believe it or not,
that smiling kid who was,
who the fuck I was when I felt safe.
All right.
But when you saw me around there,
this whole fucking guarded thing that you see,
that's all it is.
That's just like stories.
Cause Cause I get asked this when I go,
you know,
every now and then like people know I'm pals with you or start in New York with
you and you'd go do these radio shows.
I love it.
A couple of Fellas,
you do the radio shows and they're like,
what's,
what's burl like,
what's Bro?
And I always say that we used to go to Yankee Games together.
We'd go to sporting events together.
I went to a million Yankee Games and I just sat there rooting against them.
You would go,
wow.
Appreciating what,
especially the 98 Yankees as best fucking team I ever saw.
So this is 2001 [inaudible] no,
this is probably 2000 I was 2001 game that night.
Never did it.
And I,
that to me,
he gave me so much shit for doing that bus Gig that I,
I never,
I told him I didn't do it,
but I never gave you a name modeled.
I never told her.
You were telling me you're like,
I will never,
he said don't say that cause you'll get shredded for the rest of your life if
you tell.
They did a headlining set.
It was old school.
45 minutes.
Yeah.
Upstairs at the seller,
Patrice,
Kevin Vos,
Norton,
Keith.
All the killers were there.
Yeah,
they did on a fucking hour on what my bus Gig was going to be like trashing me
and dude,
it was so fucking,
they crushed me.
So hard strangers we're listening and laughing or worse.
There was a couple of women going,
oh cause they were looking at my,
I had nothing.
I got fucking,
so you gave me this Gig to Gig was basically you go on a bus and like from
midtown to Yankee stadium you had to do standup comedy.
These guys from Atlanta had come up.
It was the Braves,
there was a second time the brace.
It was 99 is that right?
Nine.
No,
no.
What the fuck will 2001 world series 2001 is Arizona.
This is also,
it was Arizona,
Arizona pitch.
Okay.
So the Arizona Diamondbacks,
he,
so these are fans from Arizona and they had rented a party bus to go from their
hotel up to the fucking Yankee Stadium and they wanted a comedian in that
fucking traffic.
I can't imagine how much time he had to do to do stand up and in return you've
got a world series tickets and I was just like,
dude,
I'll fucking cause up bomb.
I'll just sit there all I gotta do shit on the Yankees for an hour.
I can do that for fucking a day.
I'll take the ticket and I'll fucking leave.
But then you it and you couldn't do it.
You said,
here's the opportunity,
do it.
But don't tell anybody.
They teased me out of it.
You know what it was.
It wasn't even the trashing.
It was after the pounding that I took and they all left and I was just sitting
there like a punch drunk fighter and Patrice Zack down,
what's next to me in this fatherly way.
He said,
Bill,
I will stand in front of that bus before I let you do that Gig.
If you want to go to a world series,
buy a ticket,
you got the money.
And it was the first time I ever thought like,
wow,
I think I've earned some sort of self esteem as a comedian because you come up
every,
it's just one impossible situation after another that you start to get
institutionalized.
That dude,
I remember one time I went to,
I had to do this Gig at a,
it was called a birth,
a private gig birthday party,
I think Linda Rowe booked at or something.
I don't know.
She booked this fuck,
I love her.
She booked me at this thing.
I think it was her.
It was Roger Paul,
one of those too.
Yeah,
and I went there and what it was was it wasn't a birthday party.
There was a Irish guy getting deported because he got caught for fucking helping
out the IRA and I just remembered he went up first and I don't know who he was
talking about,
probably Margaret Thatcher,
one of the English cons.
And he was like,
I got fucking two words for them and it's not happy birthday.
And the whole place goes,
I goes nuts.
And they all marched up to the bar and started drinking.
And only the women where they're not paying attention.
I was standing there,
fortunate it was two other comedians bomb all those fucking prom shows that
stand up.
New York used to book and Dangerfield stage of us.
You have to do a half hour for the prom shows just for people who don't know
you.
You would show up in these fucking kids in the prime of their lives.
They just want to have a good time on a boat and it was on a little boat cruise
around the island of Manhattan and they would have the dance music going.
They would cut the music and then you had to walk out into the middle of the
dance floor and start doing standup fucking comedy.
I did one crew,
one.
What was good?
They actually put them in a room and I had like a chance like,
dude,
I can't even remember the gigs.
They were that traumatic.
They just sort of like flashes and then you would bomb and then you're on this
boat.
You can't leave.
I put treats.
Would've stood in front of that boat,
said pill.
I know dude.
I used to hide down by the engine room and then you had to make,
then you had to make the decision as the boat was pulling into,
I try to get first in line and feel them staring at the back of my head or do I
hide here like a rat and wait for him to get off.
And at one time I,
the first time I hit like a rat and right as I thought they'd all left,
there was just one of them walked off songs is black kid.
I remember just looked at me,
I can't do the,
it's a face.
He just looked at me,
kind of pursed his lifts and just slowly shook his head as he was looking at me
and he was looking at me like,
man,
I dunno what the fuck you were thinking that you'd ever be good at this shit
just so that's why I say yes to the buck cause I was just like,
I've already done gigs way worse than this bus story and I'm getting a world
series ticket out of this.
I'm actually pissed at myself that I didn't do the Gig.
I did it.
And thank you for it.
Cause I got to see George Bush through the opening pitch out and it was when he
nailed it to he fucking nailed it.
Yeah.
Fucking after nine 11 it was like a euphoric kind of vibe in the stadium.
The rest of the world had had empathy towards us before.
He kinda liked us then and yeah,
felt we were victims and then I forget who,
but this pop fly comes up and this guy in this kid go for it.
[inaudible] and this guy catches the ball and this kid's kind of like still
standing there and the guys turn around waving the ball and everybody in our
section starts pulling this guy.
Boom.
Get the kid the ball,
give it to a kid,
to a kid.
You start chatting.
I start Jack,
give it to the kid,
the whole sections,
give it to,
it's starting to spread all the sections neighbor and give it to the kid and
this guy's getting pounded.
People are not letting up.
It's going on for two minutes,
three minutes.
And eventually the guy stands up and he turns around and he makes a fucking
production.
He holds the ball out so everybody can see any hands it to the kid.
Right.
And the kid stands up,
everybody claps,
you go,
you're fucking caved.
You should've kept the ball.
But I started laughing.
You go smoke this,
everybody else is smoking it.
And then everybody starts pounding this guy and you on their own.
It's about peer pressure is so fucking funny.
Everybody was dying laughing.
It was the only time I saw comic get like laughs at a stadium from the crowd.
I've always killed at stadium money.
Oh,
I always killed the stadiums.
And there was a,
there was a thing,
I had this one weird fucking,
this weird,
I would become a different person when I went to a game for awhile.
Yeah.
But if this was before I was known,
cause now they're like,
oh let's set jerk off from comedy central.
So now it's not fun.
But before anybody knew who I was,
I would go into a stadium,
dude,
I would be on the road.
I used to embarrass Paul Versey.
I,
one time I got,
I don't know,
I would just become completely uninhibited.
And it was just all about making my section laugh and trying to have like a good
set.
And this is before all those flatscreen TVs came in and killed the class clown
at the sporting event because now everybody's just sits there staring at him.
Cam.
Yeah.
So I was at this,
this game,
uh,
it was the dolphins verse,
the Bank Bangles,
and I was yelling all of this shit,
you gotta be bored,
you gotta be on Shit during that game.
Right.
And I put,
I want to go to all the stadiums,
so,
and which I basically have,
I've got six left in the four major.
Um,
but then I found out some rich guys already done it,
the fucking cunt.
Um,
so,
uh,
I was trashing the dolphins because they were right in front of us and I was
doing such a good job and they were all laughing around me.
And so he said,
hey man,
get,
cause it was a close game.
Get on their kicker,
get on their kicker.
So I just,
this guy carpenter and I just focused in on this guy and this at this point they
had the flat screen TVs but it was the bangles who were like barely in the NFL,
you know their stadium and shit.
So it's just like they don't have like a lot of like crazy shit going on.
So I started in on this guy carpenter first.
He always starts at you're a liability and I had to make sure that he didn't
curse cause it was kids around there and I just started with this guy and I
swear to God I ability,
yeah I was yelling shit about him getting his,
it's not too late to get your real estate license.
And I was talking about his career after football and I swear to God he picked
up his tea in the net and he moved all the way down to the other side and I'm
convinced,
okay,
I want to believe it was because of the Shit I was talking.
I mean the guy is the guy still had a great career then he went up.
But it was funny cause I never forgot his name.
Then I saw him in like Buffalo.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I call versus he up there he is carpenter.
Um,
I did a couple of times I felt like I got to somebody.
One time I went to a game at Old Tiger Stadium or Briggs Stadium as my dad would
call it and I sat in,
I wanted to say it was the only state that had an upper deck all the way around.
So I sat in the upper deck,
the short porch out in right field and they would,
there was an inner league game.
They were playing the pirates.
See now the center field and left field or play catch in the right field was
playing catch with like a backup catcher or something.
So he was playing in the guy who had just the guy in right field had just hit an
inning ending double play.
And I started in on him about how the,
you know,
you do shit like that.
That's how he gets sent down to the minors.
You're on the pirates,
you're barely into the league and the league and you know,
and it's the short porch from hanging over this guy yelling and dude,
he threw his next pitch this next throat and I swear to God it's sailed like
eight feet over the guy's fucking head.
And then I felt bad.
Then I felt bad.
You're the cooler now.
It's just like,
hey dude,
I was just fucking with you man.
I mean,
I'm just trying to break it.
I don't even give a fuck about the tigers.
I'm just being an asshole.
Um,
I had a buddy of mine,
he got somebody at Fenway Park one time.
He was yelling at the relief pitcher and he was screaming,
yeah,
all of this shit at this guy.
And this guy is just stone faced.
Yeah.
Not acknowledging any of it.
And then finally just quiet,
got quiet.
Then my buddy just goes,
I know you can hear me right.
And the guy broke into a big smile and just started fucking laughing.
He just started fucking laughing.
And then the whole section laughed.
And like the guy that's,
you know,
that was,
it's actually comedians,
IRA proctor,
Boston go.
Yeah.
I know you can't hear me.
What am I favorite?
Something like that is,
um,
I did this college,
oh,
years ago in screech was just coming on the comedy scene.
Diamond,
right?
Screech.
Yeah.
Dustin diamond dust and diamond and use with Michael Diamond.
I got booked at this,
um,
you know,
this college campus.
And so we were double booked.
So they're like,
you know what,
Steve,
why don't you open and screech will Dustin diamond?
We'll close the show.
What fucking time it is.
I can make sure I don't miss this shit.
It's only 1235.
Well,
we're fine.
Oh,
we started early.
Okay,
we're good.
We're fine.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I go,
yeah,
I don't give a shit.
That's fine.
Yeah.
You know,
this is a good payday.
There's colleges back in the day.
So they put us in this big campus theater,
whatever.
It's like 5,000 kids.
And I go up and I'm like,
I'm like,
you know,
if doesn't diamonds going after me,
I'm going to bury this fucker.
So I just,
I,
I pull out all the 4th of July fireworks,
you know,
do 20 or like my best,
like hard hidden sellers stuff.
And he goes right to bury a childhood child star.
That was just kind of like pissed at the time.
Mike,
I was still kind of like,
you know,
you would take in your childhood out on them on safe money ever enough,
with,
you know,
his residuals,
he's not making shit.
It's so you,
you,
okay,
so you tried to bury [inaudible].
What happens when you're a little younger and this guy's coming off the TV
credits?
It's like fuck it.
Okay.
So,
so yeah,
you're probably right.
But anyways,
I go up to my thing and in screech goes up and I,
you know,
used to get that grace applause five minutes it starts to dissipate and
eventually it's just silent.
And it's like that scene in Andy Kaufman's movie,
the Jim Carrey one was doing that college and slowly people are walking out of
the amphitheater and stuff.
I kind of felt bad and I was going to say then,
how'd you feel Steve?
I felt really bad.
I felt bad.
We all have those moments and it's silent.
It's quiet.
He just did the joke,
the POVs and just absolute pure silence.
Just you could hear a pin drop and then just way in the back from a rafter in
the back of just your fuck you screech and I fucking couldn't stop laughing.
I don't think I've ever laughed harder cause it echoed,
you know,
and it was just so quiet and it was just way up and I was fucking in tears
crying so hard.
It was one of the worst like moments where somebody just says something at the
right time,
it's crushing,
it's fucking soul crushing.
And then you see all that shit that he ended up doing.
Then he's got to grow the beard.
He's got to try to seem edgier,
kind a good dude.
He did porn.
That kid probably drove him to porn.
He did Paul Preach,
I bet.
Still echoes in his head to this day.
And it made them do porn.
And this is the thing that was actually respect.
He just wanted to be the guy I yelled,
fuck you screech,
screech.
That's what it becomes.
It's just,
that's his Twitter handle.
Hey,
speaking of that,
did you,
uh,
as far as like,
dealing with like,
uh,
people know when,
who you are,
did you see that documentary on Bill Murray yet?
No.
Is this documentary,
this kid made about a hills bill?
About boomer?
Yeah.
Like seeing,
it was all these urban myths about,
you know,
hey,
we were playing kickball and all of a sudden Bill Murray showed up.
They played three innings and then he was just disappeared.
Or he showed up at our house party started French fry.
No one will believe this.
Yeah.
All of that shit.
So he was investigating it and all this type of stuff.
But like when you watch it,
it's just this fascinating thing to see.
It's a combination of him like living in the moment and then also,
uh,
dealing with how famous he is.
I feel that it's just like,
I'm going to go on the offensive here and be like,
so open and normal.
It's going to freak you out.
And then we're gonna meet in the middle where I'm just a guy named bill.
It's fucking fascinating.
Anyway,
mental judo.
He flipped it on you?
Yeah.
And actually taught you something and then by the time you figure it out,
he's gone.
And then you realize I didn't even ask him for an autograph.
Yeah.
So he actually gets like,
like,
I feel like this is what he does so he can have a normal existence.
You know,
one time I was flying on a little fucking puddle jumper over to uh,
South Carolina and he's a part owner in a minor league team there.
And he was on my flight and dude,
he,
I missed him by one seat.
Oh yeah.
I was in the opposite row,
opposite of the aisle,
the two seater.
And he sat on the other side of the two seat on the window,
so I couldn't hear what he's saying.
But he talked to that other guy,
the whole fucking flight.
Oh,
that's awesome.
And I was just like,
fuck,
I always almost there.
Do you ever want to be that guy?
I never,
I always hated that.
And like,
I never want to like,
like if I was sitting next to bill,
I don't know if I'd say anything,
I might be like,
you know,
I might sound,
I never,
I know,
you know what it is.
What I've found with people at that level is if you somehow know what they're
hobbyists,
they'll talk to you all fucking day long.
But if you go at them and talk to them about what it is they,
they've done press junkets around the fucking world.
Yeah.
The same 20 questions and variations of them and it's just like,
you know how perfect reference groundhog day.
And like usually he made that movie.
So,
um,
yeah,
like Isley,
you know,
and I also have no,
I don't have a desire to get to that level of being known.
Yeah.
Where you're just like,
his life is just constantly,
this is such a weird thing to say,
but being bombarded with complements that you can't get on it and then you can't
leave you,
you know,
you don't undersell.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
No,
you don't understand.
You don't understand.
It's just,
this is just,
they're not letting go of his hand and it's just like you get my aunt Vicky,
you don't,
yeah,
get it picks you.
Can you,
can you leave him a voice message on my phone?
Oh my stupid phone is not on it.
And then,
and then he walks another half of foot.
Oh my God.
I'm the biggest and it just becomes that.
Yeah,
no,
it was on video.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
No,
and you see it and you see those.
Whenever I see those people,
there's this sadness I'll do.
Do you know what's cause they're walking around that it's like they're like this
fucking,
they're like a monument.
It's like you become like a thing.
You're not even like a fucking person anymore.
Zoo.
You're zoo exhibition.
Yeah.
When I go out with Vince and like,
especially when we're in Chicago,
we walk around,
I'm the guy.
People just hand a camera too.
Yeah.
Just go take this.
And then he handles it really well.
He was really good at it.
He's good at,
he's great but,
but then they,
but he likes people.
I think there was like people,
I think you have to like people,
but if you're like,
you're fucking curmudgeon,
like me,
I don't think I,
yeah,
I like,
I'm acting like this is an option to get that fucking big,
but I just,
when I look at it like that's something,
when you get into the business,
you think,
oh,
I want to win an Oscar and I'm going to direct the fucking movie and I'm going
to fucking a,
and I'm going to do this.
I'm gonna do all that.
And then you,
when you get in,
and first of all,
you see how fucking hard it is.
And then secondly is you,
when you actually start to see what that thing is you kind of,
I looked at,
I was just like,
oh,
it's creepy.
Yeah,
you can't eat.
You can't one that now.
Now with those fucking like everybody's,
it's like j Edgar Hoover,
everybody's got like a fucking camera now.
Like I was saying with your dude,
the fact that they came at you and could just stay,
fuck you jaggy chair,
you fucking Asian,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then to a chair,
you,
there is no evidence of it.
And then they just walked out and Nathan happen.
Nothing happened.
But like these days they'd be fired from the night shift at best buy.
You know,
it's like that's,
yeah,
like Oh,
shots fired there.
I saw what he just did there.
I saw what you did that,
that,
that would be like the,
the thing.
But um,
well Jesus,
you know what Steve,
I don't know.
This has been fucking great.
Just to go back.
It's funny how we go down memory lane and there was like,
no,
they were just all brutal stories.
That's what I always thought.
That's what I always the worst story that ever happened to me.
You always said it's the meanest thing you've ever seen.
Bobby [inaudible] Bobby.
Ah,
that's the worst.
I think if we,
if we close it out,
you know,
we,
we tell people that years ago that Patrice O'Neal roast,
it was a pretty tree.
So Neal rose,
which was the purest and greatest fucking rose I ever saw in fortunate.
I got to be a part of it because it wasn't for anybody else.
It was for us.
I know now,
I think there's tapes of it,
you know,
everything ends up online now.
But like,
uh,
it was at the old Boston comedy club and the amount of people that showed up
cause they finally want to see somebody shut Patrice up.
Cause he had trashed all of industry there.
Everybody was.
Yes.
And they wanted to see what happened.
So Bobby,
when you can tell this what the stores I,
I got,
I was married,
I was just about to get mad on some level that would tell them this story
though.
I was managed by Barry Katz at the time.
I don't want fuck Bobby last time.
I love Bobby by the way.
There's no way not to love Bobby cause you always get to a fuck Bobby.
And then he just out of these enormous you,
the last time I saw him in New York City I was wearing,
my boss had,
Bernard did see to the bottom,
he goes,
take your ball cap off.
I go,
okay.
And he goes,
oh he's still got hair.
And he walked away.
He was upset that at my age I still,
he wanted me to be bald and then he'd be happy.
Like that's,
that's who Bobby is,
you know?
I know.
But you have to understand the sadness behind that.
So anyway,
very guts manages me.
He's like,
Hey I got you.
Was this before or after you became a dad?
Cause he's a different guy now before I know now he's now,
he's like Bobby saw Bobby now he's good,
Balmy Santa Claus box.
The Bobby.
We always want,
we always Bosley knew he could be.
Yeah.
Cause I will say this about Bob.
He has been 11 different people since I've met him and each in each version has
been a better Bobby's it.
Yeah.
He never went in a worse direction.
You definitely may be stylistically with clothes for awhile during morning he
moved out to la and he was starting to look in a little Cholo.
Yay.
Yeah.
I don't know what happened.
He came out here and he,
he lost use performing at Kinston years for a good year.
I think
so.
Can,
I remember Keith said that he said,
Bob,
move on to La as a Puerto Rican.
He came back a fat Mexican,
we got bail,
we gotta get them out of La.
It's killing them.
Cats gets me this like audition at SNL,
but,
but not like the audition where you go,
you've got to put yourself on tape.
So there's three characters,
three impersonations.
This is like again,
probably like late nineties early two thousands cell phones are not out.
Nobody has
that tech.
Yeah,
I remember that was a cattle call to try the next to find the next young hot
talent to be on SNL.
And you had to put yourself on tape.
So you borrowed Bobby Kelly's
camera video camera.
He's very tech savvy and I borrowed his camera and I put it,
I put a DV tape in there and let it run for an hour.
I just sat in front of the camera and just let it run instead of stopping and
starting.
And I was like,
I'll just edit out.
I'll just edit the and get the best parts and that'll be my tape.
So I give Bobby that the camera back and I give them,
I leave the tape and I go,
feel free to tape.
You forgot the tape was in?
No,
you left.
I left the tape in there.
I go just tape over it.
Cause those are kind of expensive at the time.
Jesus Christ.
Steve,
you know what you would dealing with?
I'm a trust.
You have thought you forgot it was in there?
No,
I'm a trusting person so I,
I gave him,
it was like a three pack,
so I gave them two extra tapes.
I said,
so Bobby Kelly invented the dark web.
You,
he's the man.
Yeah.
Whenever they do the documentary on the dark.
He's like a,
he's like a,
a cataclysmic moment in the dark web.
And you've left that so you,
oh,
I always thought,
I thought you forgot it was in there.
No,
no,
no.
I left it in there.
I go.
Just,
I just am having less sympathy.
You knew who he was.
So he,
what he does is at the Patrice Roast,
he doesn't even prepare months.
No,
no,
no.
You gotta wait.
You just tell him this too fast.
He fucking uploaded to tell you.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
Yeah.
Onto this computer and then kept it.
Oh yeah.
I kept all of it for like a year waiting for the perfect time to unveil it.
Yeah.
And then he,
he edited together the worst,
the absolute oars.
Me Talking to myself,
the most embarrassing things you singing Donka Shane.
I was doing Wayne Lukas.
Yeah,
Bud lite commercial at the time it,
dude,
let me tell you some,
even the best version of that was probably horrific.
Yeah.
The worst version of it was absolutely abysmal and probably an insured.
Why never worked in New York City?
Probably after that.
But he took it,
edited together,
this awful presentation of my as audition and instead of doing material,
he wheeled out a TV with the videotape and put the VCR tape in and you were
there.
This is what he did.
He went up and he tried a few jokes.
Oh,
that only did okay.
And he was like,
fuck yeah,
you might have back.
And then he started telling his story of how you left this tape in and you have
to see it.
It's so bad.
And it made no sense because you weren't there.
I was emceeing at the comedy cellar so I can go.
We weren't roasting you and then he put it into it.
It was so fucking bad that the meanest people in stand up.
I remember sitting next to Lake Great Greg Giraldo and we were going,
shut it off,
turn it off,
Bobby,
shut it off.
And that was the end of his set.
And I remember,
dude,
I came over to the seller,
people I,
and I saw you.
I saw you dude.
Shoulders slumped.
And I came over.
I said,
I go,
hey man,
I apologize.
Said sorry about that.
And you said,
I'll never forget it.
You look,
you barely looked at me like I'm surprised you're even talking to me.
And I tried to tell Bobby afterwards,
now this is Bobby.
Five versions ago,
the new Bobby knew Bobby wouldn't do this.
Bobby is like a fucking iPhone.
Daddy.
Bobby wouldn't do this.
Yeah,
not,
not Daddy,
Bobby.
Yeah,
but this is,
this is,
this is post Cholo Bobby,
he's like an iPhone.
Every version gets better.
I'm telling you,
he's a better person than I am right now.
And I'm not just saying that like,
he's a fucking amazing dude now.
But back then he was dark,
wet,
dark web.
Barb.
I tried to explain to him going and me fucking crazy.
He'll have to explain.
He was going,
is he?
He was like,
he was,
but I think going back,
that may be,
it was starting to enter that he did something fucked up.
But the thing about Bobby,
so is you just talked to him and you hear how he was brought up and it's just
like,
oh now I get it.
Cause he was the,
Bobby Kelly was the first guy I ever met who's line was further down the street
than mine because you know that thing,
you know,
all the black comics tried to teach the white comics how to sit around and you
know,
bus Paul's,
as we called it,
like I remember me and Bob where we lived in that game.
Never got to laugh.
People like God damn Jesus Pill Shit.
They would just make funny your shirt.
And we lived in,
yeah.
At least my mom isn't dead.
Yeah.
Like,
and it's just,
there wasn't a joke.
It was just,
it was fucking mean.
And he was the only guy I met Sunday mean Bob has to do with fucking,
I might do a poll,
I'm back there,
this,
uh,
summer if I get a chance to go out and do his podcast.
Oh,
with Bobby.
Yeah,
the shed.
If we talk about when we were actually roommates,
two of the most damaged fucking lunatics.
However,
we still had a ton of fun.
Do you know what he did one time?
This is so fucking funny.
And I was so fucking mad at him now,
but I just think of how like why did I care?
This is so funny.
He had,
first of all,
he was like,
you know,
he was a street kid,
so if anybody left anything on the fucking sidewalk,
he would bring it in like couches.
I was like,
Bob,
this probably bedbugs and fucking like fucking HIV on that.
They get this thing to fuck a fucking steam cleaning.
So somebody had left like the prototype for a stairmaster on the sidewalk,
dude.
And when I tell you this thing was bear like you ever see like you know you have
looking at work a really old car.
Yeah.
Where where like you open the hood and you look down and you can see your
driveway.
You know what I mean?
There's like this just bare minimal parts.
This was the stairmaster version of this.
So we were in this thing where we were trying,
we would like having this war.
Yeah.
Which is so dumb to do this with Bob because Bob's going to win and it was just
basically he fucked with my computer.
I fucked his computer.
He fucked with my food.
I'm fucking with his food and whatever I did,
I've gotten him last.
Yeah.
These fucking practical jokes.
And we're doing this in a railroad apartment where I had a walkthrough bedroom
and he slept in the living room.
That's where we lived.
It was like fucking,
you ever see those?
Those things really stick a tiger and a lion in a pit to see what happens.
Yeah,
they just kill each other.
That's what the fuck happened.
So he's on this fucking stair master and I had an audition for Conan O'brien,
which I know bugged him.
Yeah,
I know.
Bugged him because no one was appreciating how funny he was cause he was
considered crass or whatever the fuck it was.
Right.
So he was on this fucking stairmaster do.
Okay.
And it's a railroad apartment,
so where he is in the living room.
Okay.
Then to the right,
there was a little hallway that led into the kitchen and in that little hallway
was adore also to the right that led into the bathroom.
So I was on the same side,
the same wall that he was on in the bathroom.
Got It.
Yeah.
And he was on that fucking stairmaster and I got myself all dressed up.
I got the Moose in my hair that I used to have and I'm all ready to go do my
fucking audition at the comic strip for Conan O'brien.
And he had spent sitting there with you.
Remember those racquetballs,
those blue racquetballs.
He had one of those in his fucking hand and he was on this thing,
dude.
And when I tell you like Roger Clemens,
I'm coming out of the bathroom,
he can't even see me.
Like a pool shot.
Yeah.
Throws like a fucking 90 mile an hour heater.
It,
I mean I heard was it hit the fucking wall and Doodie came right in and hit me
right in the mouth.
Really?
Oh my lip fucking split.
And I was bleeding and he was on,
I remember he was on,
he was on the stairmaster laughing and then he felt bad to my lips swelled up
and
audition and I got like a piece of cheese.
Yeah.
Did you get it?
I think I might've.
I don't think I did.
I think it was suggested to them to know who I was.
Dude,
I literally,
I mean I tuck my shirt in like this is how much I gave a shit about this thing
and Bobby,
like it's,
it's one of the greatest things anybody ever did to me as far as like a
practical joke.
Dude,
if you just did the degree of difficulty,
if he was standing flat footed,
could never do that again.
This guy was on a fucking was skinny Bobby.
He was on a stair mass.
That's how skinny he was.
Yeah.
Did he this,
this,
this was matinee idol.
Bobby.
There was one time he told me he got the,
this is a video cameras you could communicate like set it up.
I love of this.
It always ends up talking about what?
Shitting on Bobby.
Bonnie.
Yeah.
We're not shitting on him.
Come on.
No,
no,
of course.
But,
but he got this little video camera that does what facetime does,
right?
It's facetime before facetime.
Right.
He's like,
dude,
you got gate when these cameras are great.
So he,
he shows it to me.
He's talking to Dane Cook on the thing and I was like,
I still have a mini disc player and one of these boxes.
Cause he told me that that was the latest thing and tells me to buy this thing.
I buy it.
He's the only one I know that has it.
I call them up,
I go,
Hey,
what's up?
He hung up on me.
I never used it again.
The great thing about being friends with 10 bucks.
Yeah.
But the great thing about being friends with him is like the,
the you just,
if you just drafted behind him,
like if you were in a bike race.
Yeah.
The amount of technology shit that he would just sell to you.
Ah,
well you load,
he was like,
he was the king of that.
He would,
he would get something of fold up bike of fucking like the some James Bond level
flashlight and then six months he hates it and he gives it to you and it's Kinda
cool that he hated it.
He was just sick over it.
He know,
he knows what the next thing is.
Yeah.
Cause he's constantly buying the new shit.
This one time I was,
I was rollerblading,
I was playing roller hockey in central park and some of broke my stick,
some rollerblading at the time in Hell's kitchen because Bobby and Norton lived
in Hell's kitchen and I'm coming down like ninth avenue or whatever.
And I see Bobby and Norton walk out of a Starbucks and they look at me and they
just start dying laughing cause they see me in rollerblades and they're fucking
howling.
They,
they're,
they're not going to cross check them and they didn't see you.
So I come skate and down and I'm walking,
they're walking towards me,
I'm skating towards them and I'm going like I'm making my way through the middle
of them.
And they both had their coffees in each eye.
I just smacked the coffees out of both their hand skating and then I turned
around and they were both dying laughing.
So it was like,
it's like those all those guys,
you know,
it's what they do.
I love those guys.
Um,
is the only thing I miss about the east coast,
but you know,
something,
I go back and it's,
it's not the same because not the same as where I went to the seller a little
bit ago and the sellers the same.
But the vibe upstairs is not the same.
Somebody said it's like going into like a one of those coffee bean.
It's just like all of the every reason that you were afraid to go in there now
is gone.
Yeah.
And what they don't understand is that we were all scared.
Like what I can't stand is how soft people are running shit now.
It's like it's not making it better to make everything.
So if this is so fucked up,
dude,
I was just,
you know,
I had to go to the doctor.
Right.
I got,
I didn't realize I got super dehydrated on this,
this fucking flight back from uh,
Israel.
Right.
Like it was on a plane for like 24 hours and I'll just watch five movies and
didn't drink anything.
Shit.
That was the next day I felt like I had the clap or something.
It was just like,
just like I didn't fuck anybody.
I know what the fuck's wrong with me.
Yeah.
And I just been drinking like pure cranberry juice for two weeks and I'm finally
better and,
but I had to go to the doctor just to make sure everything was all right.
Right.
So,
uh,
there was a diner downstairs so I out of the old school diner has like the
fucking,
you know,
you can just sit at the,
uh,
at the little bar area or to some bacon and eggs and they had the sports
illustrated swimsuit issue.
Yeah.
And like Tyra banks is on the cover.
Right.
Still looks fucking great.
Match crushing it,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
I'm like,
all right,
so that's that little thing that you know,
now they can see that she's in her forties and we're progressive.
We put it on the carpet,
dude.
I opened the thing up and the first two thing is too fat chicks in like string
bikinis.
And I'm like,
all right.
They had to do that just to be like blah,
blah blah.
And then I turned and there's a hottie then there's like an older woman who does
Palladia who looks good for her age,
but I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
And then there was another one that was like another tune.
It's just like,
what the fuck?
I just laughed.
I'm like,
got the Trans in the rainbow.
I didn't even see,
but it's just like,
get it.
I,
it's just like one of those fucking things where I just stick.
It's so fucking funny.
Like,
like why can't you just accept the fact that you're not attend the way I do.
Like I,
I never looked at Brad Pitt in fight club and be like,
Whoa,
you know,
we just created an impossible image for me to live up to.
Now I have to have a pack abs.
It inspired me to go to the gym.
I know I'm never gonna look like,
but they don't have to put like,
like on the cover of men's health,
they don't have to have some guy with like a beer belly wearing a half a shirt.
So I can feel better about myself and feel safe enough to open the fucking
magazine Dude.
These people that are incredible shape and that are beautiful and everything,
should it fuck it,
inspire you or whatever to to to do something with you fucking life.
Yeah.
Because they never talk about the other side of being that good looking where
it's just like those people's careers are over and they're fucking thirties
yeah.
Big.
That's why Tyra banks is so smart that she,
she did the whole thing where it's now,
now I'm going to pick the next good looking,
whatever,
you know,
but model whatever the fuck it is that they do over there.
Like when everybody's trying to appease everybody,
like when Mcdonald's,
after that dot came out and it's like,
oh,
we got to be healthy.
It's like,
no,
you gotta be Mcdonald's.
It's why I like Carl's Jr calls you and you're like,
do you eat like shit?
Then fucking come on down.
Right.
Cause we,
we don't give a fuck.
We'll put a Taco and I've seen comedians do that.
Camino,
there's no jokes here.
And then they tried to be the series coming,
not the fucking serious comic.
Don't be that guy on the list to do.
This will be a whole nother hour for you.
This let's just,
let's say a,
the name of the documentary is always amazing.
It's amazing.
It's available on the all things comedy,
Youtube Channel for free,
June 3rd muddied youth or it would Monday do third.
It's free,
it's on Youtube.
Check it out,
spread the word.
And then you and I,
you were gracious enough to come down and do a great role for us in the opening
act due to hook me up,
film about my early years in stand up and that's going to come out later on this
year.
So everything,
Dude,
I'm proud of you man.
Cause you're making your own opportunity out here in so many people just sit on
the couch and bitch and you're fucking work in your ad.
I could tell by that inhale and exhale,
you just did how fucking tired you are.
Yeah,
no,
I totally respect what you're doing and you're,
you're making your own way.
And when you do that dude,
you become,
you know,
is invincible as you can be out here.
You got to bet on yourself,
dude.
So yeah,
I'm proud of you,
Steve Byrne.
Everybody,
thank you so much for coming down.
You got to bill.
Thanks for having.
All right.
Is He advertising helix?
Helux he lose sleep asleep quiz that takes two minutes to complete and they use
the answers to match the body type and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress.
Whether you're a side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
like a plush or firm bread bed,
sorry,
with Helickson he likes,
there's no more guessing or compromising.
So just go to helix,
sleep.com/bird take their two minutes sleep,
quiz gross and no match you to a mattress that will keep you,
uh,
give you the best sleep of your life.
For couples,
he looks can even split the mattress down the middle,
providing individual support needs and feel preferences for each side.
Helic sleep was even awarded the number one best overall mattress pickup 20,019
by Gq.
And why had magazine and CNN called it the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on.
They also endorsed Hillary Clinton.
Sorry that I mentioned them in a public bathroom reading this.
That's why it's echoing the unknown.
I'm not taking a shit.
Uh,
they have a 10 year warranty and you get to try it out for hundreds for 100
nights risk free rouse.
Right now,
helicase is offering up to $125 off mattress orders for our listeners.
Get up to $125 off helix,
sleep.com/bird that's Helen's sleep dot coms slash for $125 off your order.
He likes sleep.com/.
Burn uh,
it's a long story.
Why I'm in this fucking bathroom than doing rehearsals in the other room.
And this is the only fucking quiet place and rights.
Don't give me any shit but shit box.
Butcher box makes it easy to get high quality meat that you can trust every
month.
Butcher box delivers 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free or range
organic chicken heritage breed pork,
my favorite and wild Alaskan Salmon.
The salmon is wild directly to you.
Deal with the incredible quality of butcher box meat starts with the commitment
to humanely raise animals that are never fed antibiotics or hormones before
they're slaughtered.
Did we mention it's delivered right to your door?
Choose from for curated boxes,
including a mix of high quality grass fed grass,
finished beef,
free range,
organic chicken and heritage breed pork or customize your own box that you can
get exactly what you and your family love.
Butcher box also has wild caught Alaskan sockeye salmon and butcher box bacon,
uh,
that is sourced from heritage breed pigs and it's uncured nitrate free and sugar
free.
Uh,
there's no way,
no easier way to get high quality meat and you can trust there's no commitment.
You can cancel anytime Jesus Christ.
They're going to say it again.
Grass finished beef or 100% grass fed beef.
We got it means the cattle ate nothing but grass their entire life.
Uh,
for the ultimate barbecue bundle.
Absolutely free and your first butcher box plus $20 off.
Go to butcher box.com/burr in a promo code bar that's two New York Strip steaks,
baby back ribs and two pounds of ground beef.
My mouth is literally wandering.
Reading this free in your first box,
plus $20 off butcher box.com burr are
rented.
The Promo Code Burn.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burn.
It's the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
May 30th,
happy Memorial Day.
Happy
[inaudible].
You should be out at a parade for the trues,
but you're just sleep it off a hangover because you are a fucking selfish con.
You wave hello to the troops at the airport,
but when they gave him a day and you're supposed to be out there,
you lay in in your fucking bed.
You do.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's going on?
I'm in my bed too.
I notice you have racist.
I have braces too.
What's that line from?
Hi everybody,
The p for some butthead movie.
Oh boy.
Oh boy who took Tylenol pm last night.
I did.
I roofed feed myself.
Everybody you ever just really,
really,
really fucking tired.
Fucking tired.
Joe,
Joe and I slept like a fucking stone kit.
Um,
I was really tired last night.
I was nodding off.
I was on my couch and I'm,
what the fuck was I doing?
I was dealing with my dog.
Who's afraid of the wind?
He's like the wind.
Am I going to sing this whole fucking podcast?
My dog does not like wind.
It freaks the fucking thing out and it eats it's way out of its cage.
I call it the cage.
The dog trainer calls it the Casa,
which is Spanish for the cage.
No,
it is it.
Um,
I took two years of f ban.
Ya'll CBU play and Kartha means health for what he's suggesting as it's not a
cage.
Cage implies that it's something negative and you tell what?
I have a shut up.
You useless cunt.
All right.
Go Trim your fucking bitch and stay out of my head.
It's a fucking cage.
The dog is in acute breaks out of a house.
You know,
you break into a house.
Oh my God,
it's so awesome.
I have to get in there and see what kind of they have you break into a house,
but when you break out of a structure,
um,
that's not a home.
Okay.
When you don't give a fuck that your gums are bleeding and you're scraping the
chest hair off of your torso so you can squeeze through a fucking porthole that
your fat ass body can't fit through.
That's not a house.
That's not a Casa.
That's not lemay,
Saul or whatever the fuck it is in French.
Uh,
I can't think of what does it mean with a ch?
What is French for house?
Chapeau was a fucking hat.
Sh lasha me's was a shirt.
I'll show me a young,
um,
no ma'am.
[inaudible] I go fuck yourself.
I flunked.
He know something.
I actually took French one pass that then was to put,
was too dumb to go on to French too.
So they actually had French to a,
the AAA of fucking French part da and a,
I flunked so bad.
I flunked that class so badly.
My Dad made me go back to French one to get the basics.
And,
uh,
I then went back and flunked that.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Still a little sick people.
If you wonder why I'm a comedian,
that little,
that little story I just gave you right there,
then I'll let you know right there.
Then I'll let you know.
You know,
the fact that I could go back in time and do worse than I did the first time,
you know?
Do you guys ever see back to the future when a Marty McFly goes back?
You know,
and he just starts writing all the rungs and when he comes back to the future,
he's got a Toyota four runner,
right?
And everything worked out and he got the girl of his dreams.
I did that in real life.
I went back in time,
I went back to French one and I actually ended up doing worse.
So because of that,
I never liked that trilogy.
Everyone else was just going along for the ride and I was sitting there going
through this fucking bullshit.
All right.
He'd go back in time and,
and he would do even fucking worse.
Um,
all right,
let's move on here.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody,
um,
for those of you who enjoy the sound of my voice and feel like he can't get
enough of it,
um,
just in case you missed it.
Last week,
I actually was on a,
the Adam Carolla podcast.
Uh,
the most downloaded podcast in the history of podcasting.
They even had the t shirts,
some sort of Guinness Book of world's records that they set for a number of
downloads.
I was on last week's episode and I had a great fucking time.
Um,
which one was recorded live at?
Jon Lovitz is a comedy club at Universal,
uh,
fucking strip mall,
whatever the fuck you call that thing is this big thing out here called
universal.
I think they used to make movies and at some point they just made a left turn
and they were like,
let's just stick like 12 shitty restaurants next to each other and a big imax
theater.
And then we'll have some stupid rides.
And a,
I got a fail in that.
A bunch of fat fucks in Hawaiian shirts will show up.
What do you guys think?
And they all went,
yeah,
let's fucking do it.
You know what?
They were right.
Punch of fatties walking around with this swollen feet.
You have a look,
you have a look down in fat people's feet.
You have a look at that shit.
You know they're already fat because they eat a whole bag of fucking m and m's
on the way over there.
One of those giant fucking bags,
you know the kind of bag.
It's so fucking big that if you will,
making a brick wall.
If one of the bricks was just the bag of m and m's,
you would,
there wouldn't,
it wouldn't compromise the structure.
You could just concrete right over the fucking thing.
Well,
it's with the yellow brick.
That's a big bag of m and m sweetheart.
My fat fucking uncle showed up with that and uh,
I dropped it on the ground and uh,
he couldn't pick it up and we just sat there laughing at a,
I come on,
I don't know how I'll be picking it up,
but we just sat there laughing at him.
You pick it up,
you fat.
Fuck,
c'mon.
Earn it.
Earn it,
Tommy.
Hey,
look it up.
Go fairy.
Try to pick up his bag of M and.
M's.
Well,
see the problem was there was a,
there was a bit of a,
a,
I probably have 15% grade in my front yard,
so the fat fuck bends down and he rolled,
he fell backwards on his big toddler ass and I whacked his head off the curb.
And,
uh,
I went to jail for eight months on a manslaughter charge.
And a,
I also have to,
part of my community service is I have to,
uh,
talk about the dangers of bullying,
but in a tribute to him,
we took that big bag of m and m's.
Then we,
uh,
we put it right in the wall there.
God rest his soul.
Um,
all right,
what the fuck am I talking about?
That and the Monday morning podcast has a donation button.
Everybody do you have a dollar?
You got 20 bucks,
just burning a hole in your pocket.
What are you going to do it?
When are you gonna do with that money?
Huh?
You're going to spend it on that fucking unappreciative cunt sitting across from
me right now who can't hear what you're listening to.
Huh?
You can listen to it on your iPod and she sitting right across from her.
Look at her.
Look at that stupid fucking side of her face.
Yeah.
You married that.
You're legally bound to that.
What are you going to do spending on a 20 bucks on her?
Getting her some sort of fucking,
I dunno,
appetizer at Applebee's.
Is that what you're going to do?
Is that what you're laughing right now?
Aren't ya?
This is worth the 20.
She isn't,
she's not going to give a fuck what she doing right now looking around the room,
you know,
looking for,
for a fucking a different deck with the,
with the bigger dollar sign on it.
Uh,
you know,
you wouldn't know that this was a holiday with the amount of meanness that I'm
spewing here.
I'm a little frustrated.
I'm still trying to get over this fucking cold that I've had all God damn week.
And I'm also frustrated because I've been going on stage going off in support of
Lance Armstrong and I'm really beginning to realize how few people give a shit
about bicycle racing.
MMM.
You know,
I actually got to be honest with you,
I actually put that out there and somebody connected with the tour,
sent me an email and uh,
said he thought that the shit I said last week was fucking hilarious when I was
trashing that fucking cunt,
that piece of shit.
Tyler Hamilton,
you want,
you guys understand first of all,
those of you are actually keeping up on the Lance Armstrong story.
All four of you.
Um,
do you understand that he's not going to get caught.
The guy took fucking 500 Goddamn test.
He passed them all.
So now all they can do is just get people to say that they saw him do it.
That's not going to hold up in court.
And not to mention the people coming forward are fucking known cheats.
You know,
Tyler Hamilton,
this fucking cunt.
This is his background.
The falls or this guy,
American cyclists.
Tyler Hamilton announced his retirement Friday.
This is a an article.
October eight I'm sorry,
April 18th,
2009 Oh,
I did research this week.
Okay.
Now it's just retirement Friday.
Why?
Because he had accomplished everything he could accomplish in that wonderful
sport.
No.
He retired Friday after testing positive for this steroid,
d,
h,
e,
a which he said he knowingly ingested in an over the counter herbal and anti
depressant.
All right,
here's a guy.
He's on antidepressants and he's taken steroids.
This is the guy that's going to bring it down.
A known fucking cheat.
He was just,
it was the second doping offense for the veteran writer who tested positive for,
no,
I don't want to offend gay people here.
He tested positive for Homo logo,
a lot of blood transfusion.
You've got a big bag of semen evidently shot into his fucking veins to add to
the testosterone.
Jesus Christ out of fucked any win that year,
a Houma Globe,
Glue,
Glue Bolus,
blood transfusion 2004 and served a mandatory two years suspension even as he
disputed the test results through two rounds of arbitration.
These are the kinds of people who are coming up.
All right,
this guy's life's over.
He rode a bicycle until he was 30,
you know?
Do you realize how big a hole that is in your resume when you try to get back
into the real world and try and get a desk job?
Yeah.
Gee,
you know,
it's weird.
Um,
do you have any sort of job experience?
I wrote a bicycle from age eight to 30.
Yeah.
And um,
did I got fired?
I got fired from riding a bicycle and now I would like a management position.
Hey Tyler,
why don't you go fuck yourself?
So then what does he do a lot?
Jesus,
what do I do?
Do I write up book?
I don't want to write a book.
That's work.
What else should I do?
What if I just go on 60 minutes and I ran out?
Lance Armstrong,
you piece of Shit Douche bag or the fucking month.
This fucking guy,
Tyler Hamilton.
You Bill.
I just can't believe that shit.
Okay.
First of all,
people,
I'm going to tell you this right now.
You can't ride a bicycle.
I said it last week.
You can't ride a bicycle 30 miles a fucking hour up a god Damn Mountain.
All right.
For a month.
You can't do that without being on drugs.
All right,
so get your fucking heads out of Santa Claus Ass.
They're all on drugs.
Okay?
They're on drugs.
Yes.
All of them.
So what are you gonna do?
You gotta take it away from Lance and give it to the other drugged up guys,
this is fucking stupid.
This is the 2004 red sox versus the 2004 Yankees are roided up guys.
Beat your,
wrote it up guys.
He wants seven in a row.
Case closed onto the next one.
I don't want to talk about it anymore.
Voices in my head stopped bringing it up.
God Damn it.
I've got to blow my nose.
Hang on a second.
I've got to hit pause.
All right,
I'm back.
Jesus Christ.
I swear to God.
If this fucking cold last one more damn day.
I'm shaving the mustache right out of my beer and I'm going to look like fucking
Abe Lincoln.
Nothing worse than blowing your nose when you got a mustache.
It's like a four hour process.
All right.
So anyways,
back to the damn podcast.
Speaking of sports,
um,
how bout those Boston Bruins,
Huh?
All you fucking heinous.
Where's your team?
Huh?
Are there out there?
Little fucking charity.
Golf game raising money for cancer.
That's what they're doing.
There's only two teams left.
People,
the Boston Bruins and the Vancouver Canucks.
The only professional sports team that throughout it's history has dressed worse
than Sinbad.
The ugliest fucking uniforms,
ladies and gentlemen known to fucking man known to all of sports for a good 20
fucking years.
Horrific apps.
They came out of the gate with one of the great uniforms of all fucking time.
And then what happened?
What happened in the 80s they decided we need to switch it up a little bit.
See,
the problem is,
is not only are they in Canada,
they're way on the west coast way out.
They don't even know what the fuck's going on.
They don't know what styles are in.
So when the fucking early eighties they switched their goddamn uniform,
something like that.
You know what it was,
was disco finally made it to Vancouver by 1982 and when everybody else was
listening to the talking heads,
right?
The last couple of police albums,
they were still up there,
do a little dance,
make a really rough,
and then they came up with the ugliest fucking God damn uniform I've ever seen
in my life.
And uh,
the away jerseys were bad enough,
but the home ones,
I'm telling you where the ugly,
there's a picture of Cam Neely,
I'm going to have it up on the f the man podcast.com,
the official fan page of the Monday morning podcast of him in that uniform.
And I swear to God,
when you see him in that uniform,
you would actually consider dropping the gloves with the guy.
That's how bad these fucking uniforms are.
So these douche bags and their little fucking mining town way on the west coast
to Canada and way out there,
you know,
they live on the other side of the fucking Rockies.
Okay.
Whey the fuck out there.
All right.
Like,
if you were in Seattle and decided that you were going to drive to Alaska,
there'd only be one little shit ass fucking town on the way there.
And that town is called Vancouver.
And you know what's funny about those cons?
They actually think that they're cosmopolitan up there.
They got a bit of an attitude.
People they think that they have this fucking,
Oh let's do some ecstasy.
We got a couple of nightclubs up here.
All right,
so what are these dumb cunts do after they for fucking years where the ugliest
fucking hunk of shit uniform I've ever seen in my life.
I remember being in sixth grade when I saw that uniform going.
That is fucking horrific.
You know,
I'm in sixth grade people,
I just stopped coloring.
I should have loved that uniform.
That's what it looks like.
It looks like one of five-year-old number.
When you did that when you were five and you're grabbed every crayon in the box
and you just started writing letters,
you know,
cause you thought that would make the fucking girl look at you.
You know,
cause you knew you wanted to do something to but you didn't quite know what
because there was no internet so he didn't know what fucking was yet because you
weren't allowed to have a childhood.
You know,
that's what those fucking uniforms look like.
And you know what's amazing is these motherfuckers,
they finally admit that they made a fashion error and they go back to the
original good idea that they had.
And then what do they do?
They fuck it up.
They fucked it up.
They went back to the blue and white with the little bit of green.
Then they got to see on their thing and then they got this fucking killer coming
out of the top of the seat looking like a fucking whale sent are terrific.
They just,
you know what it is.
They just couldn't 100% admit that they made a fucking mistake.
And you're just went back to the original,
which is what the fuck they should have done.
Just like the jets
is dumb.
As those green cons are,
they realize that those uniforms they wore with Richard Todd and Freeman McNeil
wear a fucking machine steak.
Terrible mistake.
Bill Parcells came in right with his big fucking bunt pushing out as dockers and
he says,
listen,
we're going back to the original.
And they were like,
Whoa,
let's slow days because we want to win.
Everybody out there is going to go out there dress like Joe Willie.
You got a fucking problem with that.
Wesley Walker doesn't have a ring rest my case.
Yeah.
Actually I think he wore it early on.
I shouldn't have picked him.
Whatever.
Marty Lyons never got a ring even though he looked like Merlin Olsen.
Ah Fuck.
Hang on a second,
Jason.
Yeah.
All right,
I'm back.
Where was I?
Oh,
that's right.
Trashing the Vancouver Canucks.
Yeah.
And that little mining town way out there on the west coast and British Columbia
.
Yeah.
So they couldn't admit that they made a fucking mistake.
So now they've got this whale coming out of the letter C.
I fucking hate it.
I went up there,
I went to a game up there and I wanted to get a fucking Jersey and I just
couldn't get myself to do,
you know,
I was like,
all right,
I'm living on the west coast now.
I need a west coast team.
I liked the Canucks.
I liked that they went back to their uniform and then I looked at it closely and
I saw that stupid whale coming out of there looking like when that fucking alien
thing comes out of that dude's stomach in that movie,
I can't remember.
You know that thing that comes out of the fucking alien,
you know?
Remember when the alien in that movie alien,
right?
Did I say alien enough times in that sentence when it opens its mouth and then
for some reason rather than using its big mouth,
it's uses it's little mouth,
that nibble thing.
That's what it has.
They have the whale version of that coming out of the letter c that just,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
Then they got to the fucking twins there.
You know who has brothers on the same fucking team isn't,
they'll have a rule against that.
I know you can't have all a bunch of brothers on the same battle ship because of
that time in the World War II when the boat got sunk and then some poor mom and
dad,
they lost five kids at the same fucking time.
Isn't that the same rule with sports?
Why do you got to blood relatives on the same goddamn tea?
Why is,
what is it like a mom and pop?
Fucking a
hard,
yeah.
[inaudible] ah,
the motherfuckers,
I'm just trying to work up some hatred.
I really don't have any hatred for Vancouver.
I really don't even know shit about your city.
You know why?
Cause you never in the nose except once every fucking
goddamn millennium.
You're hosting the Olympics.
You know why?
Why?
Cause you got snow.
It's not because you got a good fucking city.
Hey cleo,
knock it off.
God Damn dog might I have a pit bull that's afraid of the wind.
She's like the wind.
What does that song about?
She's like,
the weird is that about love last?
Do you know what?
I was watching a one of these goddamn these channels that shows,
um,
you know,
it's more Memorial Day weekend,
so they've given all their talking heads the fucking weekend off.
So they just showing a bunch of rock concerts.
And I saw though,
I,
here's,
here's my underrated,
underrated overrated for the week,
underrated the who live concert video with the isle of Wight,
um,
best Keith Moon footage you're ever going to fucking see.
I've never been that into Keith Moon.
I like the,
I love the WHO I love,
they're recorded music,
but I've never seen good footage.
It's so he's always on TV like pretending to drum,
you know,
or like magic bus or something like that.
And he has a weird way of holding the sticks.
So just because of that,
that never seemed like there was a lot of power.
And then there was that one where he blew his drum kit up and p towns in hurt is
here.
And I always find that was something,
I always fucking hate it.
I hated how they destroyed their instruments.
If I didn't fucking I,
you know,
just watching,
watching peach,
smashing a guitar.
Whenever I watched it,
I was like,
dude,
just give it to me.
Give it to somebody in the crab.
Why would you do that?
There's a bunch of wannabe rock stars in the crowd that would kill for that
guitar.
Peter,
you put that guitar down,
young man to man,
to people teased you about your big fucking knows you're a rock star now knock
it off or they beat blows up that drum kit.
It just,
it makes you sick.
Makes you fucking sick me.
Anyways,
so anyway,
so I never saw any good footage to that guy.
I already knew he was a beast.
That guy,
that guy fucking without a doubt,
without a doubt.
One of the most original drummers of all time.
Dare I say the most original rock drummer ever.
I love fucking John Bonam and,
and he lay down the blueprint.
But when I hear bond and play,
I mean he,
granted,
he put it put deep,
put a 20 years into the future,
but still I kind of could see some sort of like,
I,
I look at Keith Moon,
I don't see any link to what the fuck are you?
What do you do?
Watch Tito pointy.
It's like he was like a percussionist.
He should've been standing up with some Tin Balis away.
The guy was playing.
It's just,
it's fucking mind blowing.
Absolutely.
My blown he spent in the stacks and he's doing this thing where he slaps it on
the snare and it goes flying up in the air.
I'm like,
that's what Tommy Lee got that shit.
So that's my underrated for the week.
Somebody actually has an overrated,
uh,
what the fuck is it?
Here,
let me get,
let me,
let me overrate it.
The state of Florida's sports fans,
a Miami Heat band,
wagoners,
Florida Marlins,
uh,
Orlando fans,
Jacksonville jags are rumored to be moving at the beginning
of two years ago.
Florida panthers suck.
It's Cetera,
et cetera.
Though that is the most lazy overrated.
You started off where you're actually making some points and then you just threw
out a bunch of topics.
He just putting it on my shoulders.
I got to bring it home.
That's what you did.
You just started a project like some broad and then you're like,
can you just,
can you come in here honey,
can you come in here for a second?
What?
I thought you said you were cleaning the kitchen.
Yeah,
I know.
I just didn't,
I wanted to do behind your refrigerator.
It just move for a second.
No,
you fucking move it.
Okay.
This is what I'm talking about.
Uh,
that's what you just did to me in that overrated there.
I got to go off of that.
Let me tell you something.
I hate to tell you this.
Every sports franchise,
Everybody's bandwagon.
Alright,
go look at footage of one.
Your team sucked.
You know,
you think I was watching the Bruins after fucking Ray Bourque left and we sucked
a big bag of dicks for like three years to be honest with you.
I had a lot to do with that clutch and grab fucking awful shit.
Just a terrible period for hockey,
you know?
No wonder Tampa one a fucking God.
Damn.
I mean that,
that's,
that's why they had this strike.
They were like,
how fucking bad is our league that the Tampa Bay lightning just won a Stanley
Cup?
Did you see that Stanley Cup parade?
There was like eight people there.
You know,
I thought it was a fucking spit town.
MMM.
Yeah.
So I would say everybody,
you know,
that,
that you know,
you've got Bandwagon for Yankee Fans are bandwagon fans.
If you watch highlights of them in the eighties or when Roger Maris broke Babe
Ruth's fucking home run record.
I mean,
you could have fucking walked up to the gate and bought a stack of fucking 20
tickets all next to each other out in the Goddamn outfield.
You know?
Fuck it.
There was nobody at Bruins games.
Nobody had Celtic games.
When we suck that,
we get the big three and then all of a sudden everybody's there.
Everybody's got bandwagon fans.
MMM Man.
I also think Jacksonville's moving out because it's Jacksonville.
You know,
what do they got one radio station out there and no one gives a fuck about them.
I Dunno.
I don't think the state of Florida has bad sports fans.
They got fucking unbelievable college football,
the hurricanes,
Seminoles.
Who else they got?
They got the Florida fucking gators.
Maybe if they're fucking college sports where it's so great,
they,
they would actually show up to a program.
I don't know,
other than a Tampa.
Tampa just sucks man.
They got the Buccaneers right who just sucked every year.
But one,
why am I still picking on them?
There were the rear view mirror.
Congratulations.
What a fucking play off series that was.
I'm just,
by the way,
I'm just breaking balls by the way,
for all you dumb cons.
Who actually take this seriously?
My Belper hates Tampa.
He doesn't like Vancouver.
Uh,
no.
My teams are playing you guys and uh,
my team is not as good as your team.
So what I do is I just trash your city and if you're dumb enough to take the
fucking Bait,
I get a nice debate going.
Cause if you want to argue facts,
okay.
All you had to do was a lightning fan is just say,
well we want it know for you fucking dump content.
And that would've been the end of it.
But you were too stupid to do it.
You sat there defending houseboats for some unknown reason.
So anyways,
the Stanley Cup finals this year,
is this a Boston Bruins versus Vancouver Canucks in case you haven't figured
that out and we haven't won it since 1972 and the Vancouver Canucks have never
won it.
So if you ever wanted to get into hockey,
this would be the series to watch because the fans are going to be ridiculously
excited because one group of fans have been waiting for 39 years and the other
group had been waiting their entire hockey lives.
All right,
so predictions for this series.
I'm doing exactly what I did the last time.
I'm picking the other team and maybe I'll jinx him.
I think once again,
the other team has too much fire power.
Yeah.
With Henrik sending in whatever his fucking brother's name is.
Ah,
Ryan Kessler.
And then they got Lou Longo Longo.
You can rattle though.
You know,
Casel is just a pretty boy now.
he took all his anger out of the game.
They start the fucking play off series versus
the San Jose Sharks.
Joe Thornton goes,
you want to fight any.
And he didn't,
he didn't do anything.
He just took the face off,
skated away with is shredded j.
Crew bloody,
you know,
it's like,
what are you doing dude?
You play playing hockey.
You're trying to be an underwear model.
I don't understand what you're doing.
Ryan Kessler.
All right.
So,
but he is an American,
so I do like that aspect of them is sendings are actually a direct descendants
of um,
Nazi SS soldiers.
You know,
not,
not just some fucking regular guy worked in a fucking warehouse and then he got
put in a guard tower.
Hey,
I'm just doing my job.
I'm not,
I'm talking about people who executed that horrific final solution.
All right.
So you know,
if you're rooting for the Canucks out there,
people,
you're,
you're saying thumbs up to the Nazis.
I'm just,
I'm just putting that out there.
Just blowing the lid off that one people.
Nah,
I think it's going to be a great fucking series.
Um,
I got to feel in the Bruins are gonna win game one and just scare the shit out
of that little mining town up there.
I really,
I really got a feeling I got to fill in.
Shower is going to score a goal,
you know against all odds because he loves taking a fucking slap up when there's
no one in front of the net from the fucking red line.
And He loves to shoot right at their pancreas too.
But I've got a feeling it's going to fucking get in between his goddamn elbow
and the side.
And then the one guy goes going to get rattled.
He's going to get pulled in the second period.
Lou Chichi has got to have a goal to shut up all you Boston cons who are
trashing him.
You dumb fucks.
Shut your faces.
How many stars are we going to run out of town because they have a bad couple of
weeks.
I guarantee you at the end of the season,
Joe Cruz,
off author,
whatever the fuck his name is,
he's going to fucking George the animal steel are fucking coach for the Bruins.
Claude Julian is going to fucking say a that Lou Cheetahs is,
has a lower body injury.
That's what I'm guessing.
All right.
He's just not going to say it because there's piece of shit out there who would
actually go after the injury.
But I,
I dunno,
I think we're gonna win.
We gotta win the Cup.
Oh,
would that be glorious?
That would be enough to knock me right out of my sobriety.
You know,
I went to a fucking party yesterday and I actually showed up with a rack of blue
moon and handed it over and I watched other people drink it and I was just,
I really questioned my citizenship at that point.
Like,
am I,
am I still a citizen of this country that I just fucking did that this is how
bad I want to drink.
People actually get no conversation about booze at this party.
And somebody brought up Fredericksburg,
Texas,
which is an hour and a half outside of,
uh,
Austin,
Texas.
Never directly.
It's an old German town.
Speaking of Nazis.
Okay.
Now,
I don't know if you guys realize this,
but I'm actually mostly German.
I've mentioned this before.
That's why I have a jaw line and I don't have that 100% Irish potato face.
Okay.
I don't look like I fucking woke up face down in a plate.
A fucking mash potatoes,
like a lot of my Irish brothers too.
Okay.
I don't look like that.
I don't look
like,
you know,
I never knew my dad because he got so drunk and he fell face first into a
shepherd's pie.
And a,
is that actually English?
I don't fucking know.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So there's this town called Fredericksburg,
which is actually my middle name,
William Fredericksburg Burr.
I don't know if you guys ever do that.
Um,
and it's this all German town and evidently when you drive into town,
just like one,
one fucking street main street.
Right.
And this is where it was described to me at the party.
You know,
I barely was listening.
I was just staring at the bubbles and the guy's beer.
That's how bad I want to drink.
Now.
Um,
and the first half of it is a bunch of antiques for the ladies and the second
half though is just a bunch of Oktoberfest type bars and a,
I was thinking like,
God damn it.
I want to go to that tab and drink out of one of those big things.
We got to press it down with your thumb and have the little fucking crown open
up.
What?
The Beer Stein.
That's how bad I want to drink now people.
So I want to ask people,
people,
people of of of the podcasting world who are listening to this thing,
um,
what's,
what's the deal with Fredericksburg,
Texas.
I want to know is it worth the trip from in Austin?
What am I going to go down to the c section again down there.
I've done that a zillion times.
I want to drive up to Fredericksburg,
get absolutely shit faced and then drive home drunk back to Austin.
Get pulled over by some fucking Goddamn Coppin.
A horse.
You are staying on what state you're in is Texas.
Don't mess with Texas that are,
I know how to sweet.
Talk my way out of that.
Right.
I just unbutton a couple of buttons from my button down.
Show off a little bit of red chest there and I just start complimenting his,
his sidearm.
Is that a six shooter?
You,
you know all ideas.
Who is sick humor.
Okay.
I could put this on Ebay in,
get over a hundred grand for it,
but I got from my daddy.
You got it from his Daddy,
his daddy,
his daddy.
I just drive away.
MMM.
Did I met you?
We have a donation button on the [inaudible] podcast.com did I mentioned that.
I always forget to mention that.
So just donate whatever the fuck you can donate and uh,
I swear to God,
if you guys donate this week,
I will,
I will donate $5 towards the United Nations Fund for curing the common cold.
Do you know the common cold doesn't kill over 7 billion people every year?
Do you realize that?
Yeah,
but it makes over 4 billion people.
Unbelievably uncomfortable.
And in some extreme cases,
even in the month of May.
So please give a dollar,
gives seven,
do whatever you want to fucking do.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm going to be on the,
uh,
on,
Nhl live today.
Nhl Live at a two,
10:00 PM Pacific Time.
They're going to be calling me on my cell phone and they're going to be a go.
What do you think about the playoffs?
You know,
[inaudible] brewers.
I gotta
be thinking,
uh,
can't wait.
I cannot wait.
Um,
all right,
last week I told you that I read that story about that debt fucking Douche who,
uh,
brought in the ringer wasn't playing this guy's kid.
And then when he complained,
the parent complain,
you know,
they kept the kid on the bench
and then the next year dies kids on another team and then he's playing against
this douche coach.
And at the end of the game,
his kid didn't shake his hand and this fucking fag went to the Goddamn league is
now is saying that this kid has to shake hands.
So the dad's like,
what do I do?
What do I do?
So I was trying to think of a country way for this kid,
something he could do to this guy.
So this is a solution.
Summit came up with said,
tell that kid to shake that coach's hand for an awkwardly long time.
I actually really liked this idea holding on when the coach tries to pull his
hand away and the whole time smiling,
maybe throw a wink in there too,
you know,
a passive aggressive fuck you love the podcast.
But I think that's great.
I would actually clasp it with both hands.
Like you just signed some sort of monumental peace treaty.
Like do you know it'd be great.
Have have,
have the d you're his dad come down.
Do you remember when and when Jimmy Carter got,
um,
was that Anwar Sadat instead begging guy to shake hands,
a sign,
a peace treaty between Egypt and Israel or something like that.
And they both shook hands and then Jimmy Carter made it like a handshake
sandwich with using his hands.
Is the bond standing basically perpendicular to them?
So I think that that's what should happen.
I think he should shake the guy's hand,
clasp it with both hands.
And then you hire a Jimmy Carter look alike to fucking sit there and you just
smile and you don't let go until that guy finally pulls his hands free and you
never stopped smiling and you never stop looking in the guys.
I how's that?
I liked that.
You guys liked that solution.
I do.
Um,
does anybody else have any more stories about that?
That seems to be an overwhelming,
not overwhelming.
That's the wrong word.
Jesus.
Bill,
Jesus Christ.
The whole podcast was going great.
And then once you do,
you pick the wrong fucking word.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Read the God damn copy.
Did I ever tell you guys,
you guys always think that this,
this show is imp improvised.
It isn't.
I actually write it out and I,
I spent $15,000 on my own,
a professional grade camera and teleprompter right now.
I'm reading all of this,
including this right now.
It's just scrolling right now.
You know that whole I'm bad at reading out loud is it's all just an act.
Um,
anyways.
Does anybody else have any stories about that?
Uh,
that type of behavior rather than overwhelming?
I know it's a reoccurring theme.
That's what I was trying to say.
You know,
somebody becomes a coach and uh,
you know,
they're getting to live out this Vince Lombardi fantasy and then they start
thinking,
well,
I sucked as an athlete or I wasn't good enough to make it to the pros.
And then when they start coaching,
just immediately that competitive thing kicks in again and they forget that
they're coaching a bunch of fucking eight year olds and they start walking
around like fucking Mike Ditka,
you know,
chewing gum.
Like they just got done finishing a fucking eight ball of coke in case you
thought I was talking about pool.
I had to say of coke.
All right.
I'm sorry.
People a little congested.
Does anybody else have any stories of that?
I actually,
uh,
I had good coaches when I was grown up,
stuff on my football coach I've ever used to kick me in my fucking legs.
I only played one year of football.
My parents didn't like it cause I came home with all these bruises and they
showed up at practice and they saw the coach kicking me in my legs.
Uh,
I remember I used to move on when we were doing leg lifts cause that's what you
want third graders to do leg lifts to make sure they get that 12 pack.
So we're doing these leg lifts and uh,
you know,
whenever your legs would come down he come over and kick you in the in the side
and give you like a Charlie horse.
So I used to move my thigh pads over there over to the side.
This was the 70s people when you could kick kids,
not only could you kick them,
you can kick up in front of their parents.
It was fucking great.
Um,
does anybody have any stories that just some,
some uh,
coaches just go and totally over the top?
Uh,
here's a new sound for you guys.
See if you guys can guess what this sound is.
All right.
And it's not me blowing my nose on the mic.
Ah,
what was that?
What was that noise?
You hear that?
That might sound like me wiping up my mustache.
Yeah.
Fucking disgusting.
I'm playing hockey tomorrow and I wear a full fucking shield and I have a runny
nose.
Dean were understand what I'm going to look like.
I don't want to be looking like I'm fucking almost set the summit of Mount
Everest by the,
by my second shift.
Yeah.
Is that icicles in your mustache?
What is going on?
No,
it's just not all right.
Now that I got rid of the ladies on the podcast,
um,
speaking of ladies,
there's,
there's a little downtime between the eastern and western conference finals and
the finals
in,
uh,
the Stanley Cups.
So I had four fucking days of,
Oh my God,
how am I going to fill up the time?
And I don't know what happened.
I put on ESPN and I've somehow got into the ladies' softball fucking world
series.
I love it.
I absolutely love it.
I want to face one of those fucking pitchers
you got,
you know,
a lot of,
a lot of guys out there.
They laugh at that shit.
Gungko right?
Fucking,
I fucking put it in the cheap sheets.
If I ever flogging the dead giant them Paul,
first of all,
they pitch the ball from like four feet away
and it comes under hand cause they don't take and they do it so fast,
it looks like it's coming right out of their baby maker.
You know,
like some sort of fucking a Nolan Ryan meets some hoary stripper,
you know and you know the ones that shoot the ping pongs out of their twats
this,
it looks like the softball.
It's just coming at this weird fucking handle.
I would love to do it because they are,
ballparks are really small
so if you actually made contact,
they pitch it so fast,
it's going over the Goddamn wall and then he gets to run around.
You get to run around the bases but you don't get it.
You don't,
you're not going to get winded because I think it's like 45 feet to each base.
It's ridiculous.
Basically,
if there's no leading,
I think in women's softball because once you take a lead,
you're basically at second base or all you have to do is just,
you know,
fall down
and you're,
you're safe at second.
Actually there is leading all right before some fucking bulldog of a woman
fucking starts giving me shit about it.
I understand.
And a dude speaking of roids okay.
If you're going to tell me those women in ladies' softball,
like there's just,
uh,
there's enough women built like that to fill up fucking like nine different
teams.
Uh,
I'm not buying it.
Okay.
Those girls I'm telling you right now would run me the fuck over.
Nah,
that damn batteries ran out again in the memory was full.
I don't know what the fuck happened,
son of a bitch.
All right.
What the fuck was,
I was talking about those God damn softball ladies.
I'm telling you man,
those girls,
they did the old packer sweep,
pitched it out to any one of them where they'd fucking,
they could run over Ray Lewis.
But I'm telling you,
it's a great goddamn sport.
And,
uh,
you know what,
in Molly took a couple of seconds for you to listen to me.
You know,
go from what I was just talking about too,
what I'm talking about right now,
but in my world,
that was like five minutes and I can't remember what the fuck I was talking
about.
So that's going away.
Oh,
it's so frustrating.
I was really enjoying what he was saying about those fucking Goddamn bulldogs to
play fucking softball.
They're actually not bulldogs is some from or a couple.
They're kind of cute.
You know,
I like some fucking thick thighs.
I'll take it down,
you know,
even with that grease under your eyes.
Um,
AH,
Jesus.
Alright.
Um,
by the way,
we have a new video,
everybody.
We have new video up on the Mlm,
podcast.com.
Remember,
uh,
not last week,
but the week before I was hyping the cage versus cons MMA event where they have
cops fighting ex cons,
MMA style in the octagon at the La sports arena.
Well,
the Monday morning podcasts,
brand new man the street Jason Law had Jason Law had,
who has his own sports podcast with uh,
Joe Barton,
nick and John Camp,
an era [inaudible] is a in the name of the podcast is called men are talking.
So anyways,
he was out there.
He covered the event for us with a Sam Tripoli,
another hilarious comedian and a,
they made a really great video if you want to see what it was like.
It was looked like it was a fucking great time.
Um,
definitely the crowd was way more for the cons then a was for the cops and a lot
of tattoos.
We're gotten a lot of weed was smoked and I think you guys ought to check it
out.
It's a great video.
It's on the Mlm,
podcast.com.
So after you're done hitting the donation button right on the right hand side,
right underneath the Facebook fucking icons.
Check out that video.
Also,
I did a,
I got another video is going to be up later on this week.
I did another one of my famous internet tours of the city.
I did a tour of new,
uh,
New York City that's going to be up.
And,
um,
I actually ran into somebody not to get all Hollywood on you.
I'm not going to name a name,
but I was out at an Italian restaurant and as I was walking out there was
somebody,
a famous sitting there who hosts a talk show.
And I,
I,
and,
and it wasn't Conan and,
uh,
it wasn't that guy from Scotland.
Um,
and I said,
hey,
what's up to him?
And he mentioned that he saw my feet,
fucking watched,
the one that I did a the tour of La and I got a big kick out of that.
Go only look at the Goddamn Internet.
Famous people are on the Internet too.
I didn't realize that.
I always thought like famous people that are on TV,
so they,
they don't,
they don't watch it.
They like read books or a,
you know,
go out and go buy like a fucking Ferrari or something.
It's always just blown my mind.
Whatever we got.
We got this great video up there,
the cage versus cons,
and I'm going to have won a tour of New York City,
my tour of New York City,
which I did when I was just starting to catch this coal that was in a miserable
fucking mood.
Uh,
so might come off a little more angrier than usual,
but it seems like a lot of you guys enjoy that shit.
So definitely check that out on amm plug catch.com the official podcast page of
the Monday morning podcast.
Sorry,
we have 45 minutes and people,
you know what that means?
That means I got 15 minutes to go.
So it's gotta be time for the advice section.
And if I was actually,
if I had some sort of a production quality on this,
we would have gotten into some music right there.
It's time for advice with your hose Billy Burger.
And I'm ripping off this melody from somebody else.
All right,
dear bill,
I am 34 years old that had been married to Linda.
Ah,
cheesy names.
The name right out of the gate.
Oh,
the lovely Nia comes walking in right as I'm about ready to do advice.
What are the odds of that?
Why don't you go grab yourself a microphone?
It's in the closet.
My closet.
All right.
And don't go snooping around in there.
I got some fucking incriminating evidence in there.
God Damn fucking brides can ever keep their faces.
Adia Shit.
Let me see if I can put this in here.
Here we go.
We're going to get this going right here anyways,
while I'm reading the first one without you.
MMM.
I'm 34 years,
34 years old and been married to Linda,
my wife for about five years.
We met on an online dating website.
Isn't that amazing?
They met online and they've already been married for five years.
How long has the Internet been around?
Isn't that fan?
That's really phenomenal.
Starting to feel old.
MMM.
Um,
Nah.
Jesus.
Chris,
can you tell I hit pause again?
People fucking con.
What am I doing here?
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
dear bill,
I'm 34 years old.
He said that shit.
He's been online for fucking five guy there in years.
And we met on an online dating website.
Immediately felt a special bond.
We dated for three years,
but I knew she was the one.
Wait a minute.
Did I read this last week?
Oh yeah.
I read this one last week.
I'm on the wrong fucking page.
Jesus.
Yo.
Hey Shang on a second.
All right.
Where are the fuck are we alright advice dear bill,
I've got a few shitty things going on in my life right now that I need to vent
about.
Also,
I would like to hear your advice.
Okay.
You guys don't need to have fucking interests like that.
Just ask me the advice cause then I'll read them and sound like a shithead.
First thing's first.
I live in South Carolina and I think you can guess that that pretty much blows.
I'm 22 years old and I just graduated from college with a degree in psychology.
My job outlook is pretty bleak right now and I just got laid off from my shitty
delivery job.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is going on in this country?
This tooth has a degree in psychology and he's delivering fucking intimates
cakes to supermarkets and he gets laid off.
Um,
because I must have applied for at least 30 jobs at this point and I've stopped
applying for the ones that I'm underqualified for.
And I've started,
sorry.
And I'm still unemployed.
I don't understand why the access of entry into the restaurant industry is so
fucking high.
I can't even get a job serving because they keep telling me we only hire people
with two years of experience.
Well,
it's the law.
It's the laws of supply and demand.
You know,
if the,
if that we weren't in the middle of a recession,
you could walk in there with the coming out of prison and they'd let you work
the Goddamn Musky grill.
Um,
yeah,
I worked in a restaurant.
This is a bunch of fucking drugs.
It was such a good economy.
It was like 1987.
Wait a second.
That was right after black Monday.
I Dunno.
Maybe it was a south.
I have no idea.
I worked at this place called the sable cafe and Cary North Carolina,
way
back in the day.
And,
uh,
we used to have this Douche who you see came in,
he was on work release,
he was in prison and they wouldn't let him out so he could wash dishes and work
his way back.
Now Watch this is,
he actually worked the fucking cooking light.
He was above me,
right?
I was a busboy slash grill chefs slash,
dishwasher because the restaurant was slowly going out of business.
And that's lash,
Hadi.
As a people,
as people gradually,
gradually quit,
they would fucking,
uh,
they would just give me their jobs and an extra 50 cents an hour.
And I was like,
whoa.
Oh,
I'm raking in the dough because I sucked at math.
I didn't realize that they would pay me three 50 an hour and a grill guy,
$5 an hour.
So they went from paying a 50 an hour for two guys to paying me $4 an hour for
fuck Emma.
Dumb fucking moron.
So anyways,
there's this douche used to come in.
And I remember one time I came walking in the back and I'm doing three fucking
jobs.
We were slammed and I said,
oh my God,
I go,
we're out of glasses.
The fuck we're out of glasses.
And then this guy had worked,
release goes,
well,
why don't you wash some ah,
a novel idea.
That's what he said.
Like he was just fucking get renaissance man.
Really,
really the Shashank the fuck are you doing after work?
Huh?
Fucking carbon and God there,
hey,
watch all the steak knives.
Make sure county over here doesn't take them back with your felon beard.
You're this stupid fucking almond brothers facial hair.
If I fucking cut it still bugs me because I didn't say anything to them cause I
got intimidated even though I thought I could take the guy,
but I was like,
this guy has been in prison,
you know,
he's gonna beat me up and then rate me.
Fuck it.
I think I'll watch some glasses.
So anyways,
um,
he goes,
if I can struggle through four years of school,
then I think I can get the hang of slinging tater skins and onion rings in a few
weeks.
What is,
what is there to learn?
Uh,
all these guys trying to get a cooking job.
We'll do a serving job.
Well I thought he meant like being a waiter,
but now it sounds like he's talking about actually cooking.
Yeah.
Dude,
he can't learn on the job at a restaurant.
No,
you owe us.
Was that under dot.
I'm sorry.
They're not coming.
Really?
Oh he's a,
nobody's talking about cooking,
isn't it?
Cause I thought he said he was having a hard time getting a job as a server
because that you can learn in like two seconds.
No,
that's what,
that's what he said.
But now all of a sudden he's talking about slinging tater skins and onion rings.
I think he just means serving it.
Slinging doesn't slinging me in the,
yeah,
but there wasn't,
didn't you say earlier that he's trying to get a job as a miniature already
disagreeing with me.
Then I say earlier that he was try
and get a job.
What is it a learning,
let me get back to this.
What is there to learn in the second year of restaurant experience that you
can't get in the first year?
Even the first six months is I agree with how in the hell am I supposed to get a
job.
I'm also being cut out from financial support of my family who helped put me
through school.
If I can start paying bills that I'm going to have to move back in with my
parents and a shitty small town that is about an hour
away from the city.
I live in job outlook there is even worse than I would hate to move away from my
friends and girlfriend.
Me and my girl don't live together,
but she's offered a lot of needed support and most importantly she supports me
pursuing comedy.
It's my dream to become a comedian and I can only go so far while I live in
South Carolina.
Um,
now what is it that he can only go so far living in South Carolina?
The fuck you become on the next guy.
Damn cable guy.
Dude,
this people this.
I've guarantee you in South Carolina,
there's a guy there who's the king of South Carolina and we've never heard of
them.
Every state I've been to.
Yeah.
And they fucking make six figures a year.
I'm not,
I don't understand what he's saying.
Obviously he doesn't want to be the king of South Carolina was get it in movies
and TVs become a nationally headlining act.
I understand what you're saying,
but I'm just saying you can make fucking money there.
There is money to be made with those drug fucking idiots there all you gotta do
just do a ric flair impression.
That'll be a closing bit.
You'll be fine.
Um,
I would,
uh,
he lives out there.
I would like to move to New York City but won't be able to do that if I'm not
able to save up money.
And I definitely won't be able to do that anytime soon because I am awaiting a
trial for a Dui.
I got back in January,
he was getting like unraveling more and more.
Every sentence it becomes as something else.
That's why country songs is so sad.
These people live it
laminated South Carolina.
I love my girls vagina and I can't get a job washing dishes.
Did you just run Kara?
And I don't know why.
Because the cop was even drunk girl and me
and the song should be called.
I know I'm not ric flair cause I know I ric flair and I know auto bleach my
hair,
but I got a dream.
And would you help me get your hand off you go.
And I'm starting to get scared that run with hair.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
Um,
anyways,
the trial is this September and if I lose my license,
I will only be set further back from my goals.
Yeah.
You think I'm trying to,
not to mention our growing weed in my apartment.
It's a one bedroom with bay windows that I think my neighbors are starting to
catch on a,
I am trying to hone my skillset.
No.
Oh Jesus.
Somebody went out late last night.
I'm trying to hone my skills here,
but I can't afford,
uh,
to keep driving to open mikes that are at at least an hour away across the
state,
North Carolina,
by the way.
I've stopped drinking irresponsibly and I'm sorry that this email ran a little
long respectfully.
So itself gotta love have the politeness of the cell.
This is a respectful,
yeah,
praise.
What else?
Plantation Kentucky Fried Chicken ties on holding onto his lapels.
That's a forced call her Sam or years.
Yeah.
That's how they,
that's how they get you with the polite and the state gets with the politeness
and they do,
that's the ad.
See,
you know as someone who grew up in the south,
I know.
Yeah.
That's,
you know what that's called?
That's called hospitality.
It's masking so much.
Yeah.
Do you know what that is?
That's called the old,
uh,
it's called the old stonewall
Jackson Bill.
They'll stonewall Jackson.
He come in high.
You are surely would lock down.
You don't you look party today.
I ain't trying to be disrespectful.
Right.
And then you fucking turned the corner.
We tell you something about that board,
that board fuck mud.
If he thought a rock was on her,
a fucking snake.
Well,
what's going on with the thing here that bought fucking rock of started?
Snake was onerous.
So what is,
what is he asking?
He's asking me how the fuck he gets out of,
uh,
all this bad shit.
Right.
You live in South Carolina.
Let,
let's,
let's recap.
Shall we,
yeah.
In South Carolina,
there's a South Carolina can't get a job slinging fucking tater tots to fucking
fatties who are wearing overalls.
And somehow the crack of the Ras is still hanging out of it.
He got a Dui.
He's going to have to move back home with his parents and hour away where the
job shit is even worse than it is where he is right now.
And he got,
he,
uh,
Jesus Christ and he wants to live his dream.
I mean,
I always see one solution here other than hitting the lottery,
you got to start dealing weed.
I mean,
yeah,
right.
He's in South Carolina.
Can't he grow some Tabacchi yeah,
just start.
Just start selling a wacky tobacky yeah.
Anything,
wait a minute.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
There's something going on with this fucking the sound here.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
See people,
this is why I need you to hit the donation button.
We here at Bill Barr PBS here.
I think I need a new mixer or some new wires.
And you say something about being a psychology major or something.
Aren't you supposed to do some sort of internship at a place he doesn't do you
do school and he doesn't have time for that.
Get entry into a job.
He doesn't want to do that.
This guy wants to be a comedian.
So what do you want it to be?
Yeah.
So,
so what he needs,
he needs some sort of hustle to get them out of this shit.
All right dude.
This,
this will make you feel better.
Guess what happened to me right before I became a standup comedian,
I lost my license for drinking and driving and uh,
I didn't get,
I didn't get to start at the battery's going low on this thing.
Hello?
Mm.
Hello.
There we go.
Oh,
the thing got a plant
that's not a bad ass when it starts to come out.
This is like,
oh,
take me to,
mm,
sorry.
All right,
here we go.
I'm back.
What did I do?
I just had a fucking button here.
Now this other things lit up,
which was never lit up before.
Ah,
you fucking whore.
All right,
let's,
let's wrap this thing up.
This is what you gotta do,
Dude.
You gotta walk,
you gotta get through your Dui.
Yeah.
MMM,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't know what to tell you,
man.
You got to somehow try and find a fucking job.
Ah,
fuck.
I lived at home with my parents.
I had a day job and then I,
and I did comedy at night and I saved every fucking dime.
I drove a piece of shit car and when it died,
rather than get a new one,
I just had him throw a new engine in my old one.
So I only went like 1500 and debt rather than 15 grant.
That's what I did.
So listen,
if you want to be a fucking comedian,
you want it bad enough,
you're going to figure out how to do it.
You're in a hell of a situation there.
You got to get a fucking job,
dude,
I would open.
I take any fucking job.
You can take landscaping,
anything you can do,
um,
get through this fucking Dui horseshit.
And uh,
despite the fact that you work all day,
you can still gotta go out and you still have to do those open mikes.
You gotta do it and uh,
is hard as it's going to be.
It's gonna.
It's gonna make you tough and that's what you gotta beat and make it in the
world.
You gotta be tough.
You got to get up,
but you know what?
You've been knocked on your ass.
You flat on the back flat on your back and you gotta get up.
Okay.
Right?
The refs over you right now,
six,
seven,
most people just lay there.
I'm going to go fucking lay between my mom's titties and just say,
I quit in life.
You're not going to do that,
are you?
You're going to pick yourself up.
You should've seen the look she just gave me.
I'm trying to inspire him.
This kid is in a fucking hole,
but he can get out of it.
How it's going to suck it up.
How would you get out?
I said,
oh,
would you get out of it?
I would do like yesterday.
I have to take any job that I could get,
but I'm a subtext so maybe I could get no,
I was thinking babysitting.
You pervert.
You'd whore yourself out.
No,
I wouldn't want,
my name is Nia.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
And I got some high heel do dude.
Who Do,
who wants to fucking hit this?
I'm going to be a comedian.
You wouldn't sell your ass if you,
Oh,
if you had to sell your ass,
can you stop saying sell your ass.
You had to do it.
Thank you.
If you had need to become a lady of the evening,
a lay of the evening,
I had to do it.
I wouldn't go out on the street,
that's for sure.
How would you do it?
I would set up a,
like a website or something.
I'd be one of those high class broads.
Oh yeah.
And meet you in like the lobby of a hotel.
I'd be making it classy.
Classy.
Well what would be the theme song and your Website Dude?
[inaudible]
lolicon
little man.
Okay.
I don't even know that song,
but I wouldn't be interested in that.
And let's see if you hit,
but if you had that song and you were wearing a veil,
that would freak me out.
Why would I wear a veil?
Just that's what that song just made me think of.
Whatever.
No new ones.
No,
they just have this veil and you're doing this really bad dance and it just
cancels out your hotness.
Um,
they've already,
you ever heard of the guys yet?
We had that.
You ever have a girl?
Just do something so weird.
It cancels out like how good looking she is.
Maybe a laugh like puke cause she's so drunk.
I was thinking more like hammer toes coming out of some fucking,
you know,
Paris sexy shoes when you're going to get the shoes with the red sole on it so
you can make all those other whores jealous.
You buy me a pair,
bitch,
your birthday is coming up and I can tell you right now,
I don't know what you're getting,
but I can tell you what you're not getting.
What do you mean overpriced horseshoes?
And yet,
you know I do it last second.
You've seen the birthday cards I give you ah,
over the one I gave you last year.
That had to do it.
We had to do with golf and I just sort of scribbled it out.
They were out of birthday cards
now I told you this year that I wanted to get and the purse.
So you had all that.
Oh,
that's gay.
They didn't have the purse.
I went to the place that didn't have the personnel.
We didn't ask for it.
Right.
But anyway,
to ask for it,
right
purse.
Can I have,
are you lying?
Am I lying about what did you actually get in?
And you're going to surprise me.
No.
You know what the reality is?
No,
I never went there.
I didn't go.
I was,
I was saying what is wrong with you now you're wearing yes,
I was.
I'm still sick.
I've been coughing and blowing my nose on the head.
That's why.
You know what?
I can tell you where to go in La to get it.
We're getting,
we're getting off at here.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because you're exposing the spoiled little Brat that you are.
This is halted that mine
cause I went out and I would buy you stuff that you want and thinking that that
would shut you up.
That's not why y'all got it.
Why?
Because you love me.
Yeah.
And what do you do?
I love most about what you,
as you shut your trap.
That's what I like best about you when you're not running your yet.
And he just fucking rubbing my head as I watch sports.
That's what I like.
That's all I need out of uni.
All those stupid shows where they go fucking way to a man's heart is through his
stomach.
No,
it isn't.
Shut your trap.
Rub My head as I'm watching the game in order a pizza right then and then at
the end of the night or the night of no sexual favor cooking for you.
You love that?
Yeah,
I do love that.
Can you tell me when I wasn't here for a couple days,
you felt like at a loss because you're so dependent on me.
That's ridiculous.
And I,
you and I were walking around the apartment like woo way
I did was pathetic,
you know,
I felt like the male Stepford wife,
I was just like,
how do you know how to pay bills and do any?
Now I know how to pay bills.
You take that back lady.
I take it back.
I'm just fucking with you though.
I don't know why.
I don't know how to,
I used not a cook.
He used to cook shit.
I,
there was,
there was food and I would cook it and it would make an,
it tastes delicious,
but back in the day I made Lasagna was great.
Yeah,
it's fucking delicious.
Make the salmon too.
And that I to make that I had,
I had the beef stew,
right?
A big piece of Bailey's.
The set it and forget it to make a rotisserie style chicken.
Set it and forget it.
Yeah.
Underrated,
underrated.
That thing.
I don't know why.
I think I threw that thing out.
That why?
Because what those big weird rubber,
right gloves
handle the chicken,
those things where like the fucking sex offender was so fucking crazy.
They came with these,
these big rubber gloves that they didn't move.
That was a thing.
They were like,
they were like form to some murderers hands,
and you just had to slip your heads into them because they're so worried about
getting,
you get burned.
They didn't want to get sued and went all the way up to your elbows like Jackie
Kennedy,
but they were these big fucking Herman Munster gloves.
Oh,
and they were,
they were this all white.
Yeah.
They look worse.
Color.
They look healthy before we even got them.
But getting back to the Senate,
every get it's right studio audiences yell.
That thing was the shit,
that thing.
I made a pretty good chicken.
I made a great chicken.
Yeah,
they had it down and it came out.
It was Golden Brown and he had fucking lunch meat for the fucking week.
Right.
The old thing that sucked was on top of the way they claimed the heat with
somehow steam the vegetables.
That shit didn't work.
Oh No,
no.
So I took out my walk and that was it.
Hey,
by the way,
Aww.
How sweet is that guitar I bought?
It's beautiful.
I finally,
I bought the Best God Damn Guitar.
Uh,
I s I and that's all I've been doing for life.
You know,
I had,
I had that brutal couple of weeks right there with Nia.
I was on fucking six flights and 15 days.
I caught a code.
Yeah.
I caught a cold.
I did those two episodes of glee.
Yeah,
right.
And uh,
the one episode,
sorry,
shot on two days and then a,
and I was did DC and I did New York in the middle of that.
So every once in awhile I will actually go out and I'll spend a little money on
myself.
And uh,
I bought a Gibson SG that is white lefthanded white with the black pickup,
uh,
not black pick up the black pick guard and uh,
this thing sounds so fucking good.
Even a,
even I sound good on it.
Playing that Aerosmith this week has seasons of weather.
Hi.
Maybe you came in and all of a sudden,
you know,
you were hypnotized by it.
You don't remember that moment.
I,
yeah,
no,
whatever.
But having a good time.
I've been having a good time with it.
So anyways,
that is it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I got to,
um,
I want to thank Jason La hadn't Sam triple.
Yeah.
You got to see that video.
You guys.
Oh my God.
It's hilarious.
They just in my head is an incredible person.
Yeah.
And he had his lunch and he has an incredible podcast with Joe Barton had
called.
Uh,
men are talking,
they,
the two of them have a podcast.
Oh my God.
All right.
I have to,
these are the two guys that if you know,
if you want,
if you're going to go out drinking or if you just want to fucking hang out with
these guys,
they,
they are throwbacks old school guy guys,
guys.
These are the guys.
When I go to the rose bowl every year,
these are the guys are partners in crime partners in crime.
These are the guys I stumble into the Rosebowl with,
with Cuban cigars and then people scream at us.
We have a great fucking time.
Um,
yeah,
so that's,
that's up on the [inaudible] podcast.com if you want to donate.
We really appreciate it and,
uh,
we're going to be doing some more video.
Definitely.
Um,
and starting to add those,
you can only see that exclusively on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Um,
I think I've said that enough.
Uh,
okay.
So upcoming dates,
upcoming dates for Mr. Berger are way the fuck Fisher website.
Okay.
Bill bird.com.
I'm going to be at the Chicago Theater,
um,
on June 15th doing one of those antisocial network tours with the wonderful Cim
nor Norton the fabulous Jim Brewer.
And the always adorable David.
Tell Dora,
Dora,
yes,
these guys are all the kind.
Yeah.
David tell is a sweetheart of a guy.
I realized that we went when we went and we visited those troops at the
Pentagon,
the wounded warriors who visit these soldiers.
You know,
we didn't know what to say or whatever.
Dave was in his fucking element.
Jeez.
He fucking lit up and was going to,
I just followed his lead and it was awesome man.
Like he,
yeah,
that's so good.
You guys did that.
Oh,
and it's memorial day.
It's,
and it's been Morell de.
Yeah.
And where,
what are we doing sitting there and sweatpants and then on her bed,
you know,
should we go into a parade or something?
Um,
all right.
And on June 29th,
I'm doing the,
uh,
this is very special one here.
This is the Greg Geraldo benefit at the Wiltern theater.
All proceeds go to his wife and kids and uh,
you know,
definitely people come out to that.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a huge one.
Um,
definitely if you're going to be going to do anything,
even if you're in Chicago,
drive out the fucking la for that one.
That's right.
And uh,
what else?
Real quick,
I have the animal.
These are more antisocial network,
uh,
dates on July 1st.
I'm at the paramount theater in Seattle,
Washington.
Just south of that adorable mining town,
Vancouver.
Um,
and then on the third,
I'm going to be in Vegas.
Oh,
Pearl Theater Palms resort casino.
and guess who's not going?
No,
I'm coming.
Oh,
you're not 4th of July as the next day.
Fuck,
I'm coming out.
I want to work.
You know,
you go fuck yourself.
Yo stay in home.
You only support me.
He,
when I go to good cities,
why don't you wonder where I'm going?
I need you when I go to Tampa.
How come,
you know,
come out for that one.
I came out to Florida with you one time.
Miami.
Yeah.
In Miami.
This you only go out to the San Juan Chat.
Chat.
Chat,
chat.
Yes.
Um,
all right.
Well,
you know what,
we're becoming like Donny and Marie right now and I'm really fucking getting
Douche chills.
I got to get off this.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Uh,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next weekend.
Uh,
I dunno.
Grab your ladies titties for me.
All right,
that's it.
I'll see you next week.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.